the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the final day of rapid chess did not
disappoint at the super bed rapid and
blitz in warsaw poland players took
their time using every possible minute
to their advantage richard rapport
continued his solid play defeating
tournament leader vishwanathan anand in
a surprising queen sacrifice to come
within one point to the former world
champion despite suffering his first
loss of the event anand is in pole
position heading into the blitz section
with the rapid games behind them the
players are ready to pick up the pace
day one of blitz action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the super bad rapid and blitz health
here in gorgeous warsaw poland we start
the day in the old town market square a
beautiful landmark filled with
restaurants and just simply places to
hang out and relax well the players will
not be relaxing today because we have
blitz action let's go to the studio and
start today's round with yasser peter
and alejandra
stunning views of the polish capital as
we welcome you to the blitz portion of
the warsaw superb rapid and blitz the
second stop on the 2022 grand chess
store
good morning i'm peter swidler and with
me is yasa saravan good morning peter
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the super bet tournament in
warsaw
the kings of rapids have been crowned
but now it's time to turn our attention
to the most popular form of chess in the
world blitz chess where it gets fast and
furious first of all peter do the honors
our current standings after our rapids
has been completed
uh the settings are as you see on your
screen very very tightly very compact
with vishy uh losing that uh last round
game to reheard rapport which means that
he only has a one point lead going into
the uh 18 games of blitz and uh youngest
of duda and wesley saw in pursuit uh but
in general with h as i mentioned with 18
games to play everything is very much up
in the air well it is about blitz peter
and what do you have for us in terms of
today and tomorrow uh we only have two
days left of this event we will play a
full round robin today and the full
round robin tomorrow with colors
reversed time control is five plus two
which is on the slower side from this
giving giving our players a chance to
perhaps
consider their decision seriously once
per game
and the normal scoring system is in
place without with one point for a win
half a point for a draw
alejandro good morning good to see you
my friend tell us who are the best
blitzers in the world good morning yes
sir good morning peter pleasure to be
here in this studio bright and early
morning but i'm ready it's blitz action
baby and i absolutely love these fast
games a little bit slower than usual
with five plus two instead of three plus
two but you said it yasir we have some
of the best players in the world let's
take a look at who's stopping those fide
blitz rankings and it's hikaru nakamura
and magnus carlsen that are at the very
top but close behind we have one of our
players here at the gct wesley so and
even though levon aronian is currently
the 11th blitz player in the world this
doesn't include a great performance that
he had here in the american cup blitz
where he won 35 points moves up to
number six in the world same thing for
fabiano corona he's even higher than
what those numbers show and we have
absolutely great blizzards as well anan
duda and many of the players in the
event and other notables around here in
the studio
certain peter svidler number 27 in the
world blitz rating of 27 25 there a
little bit of a lagging statistic there
100 ramirez with 26.94 this is inactive
inactive rating i haven't played in a
while i'm defending my rating sitting on
your ceiling i'm sitting i'm sitting on
my laurels
it's called camping it's called camping
absolutely you're camping on 2694. i i
am but
does it hold
it does
it does and we'll we'll see later
actually we never play blitz that's a
weird thing varja nakobian there shout
out to the man in the van 2634 he always
does amazing but of course it's gonna be
a fun day for us we're gonna be trying
to focus on one game at a time as we
will have a hero game per round let's
take a look at some of the key pairings
and key people to follow today as we go
to our friends in warsaw anastasia and
christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day four of the super bad
rapidem blitz from location here in
warsaw poland to call all the action and
give you all the live updates i am grand
master christian carrillo alongside
women grandmaster anastasia carlovich
anastasia we had a lot of fun in the
rapid portion also we established who
the top dogs are in in that format but
what about the blitz section what
players do you have your eye set on
hello everyone hello christian always
pleasure to be here with you and
especially next to the top players who
will just start the blitz portion of
this event and um of course do you know
christian that three and a half million
people play online blitz every day and i
think it's amazing number so many many
people are looking forward to see those
games i will pick up a young kristof
duda still uh i think that he has really
great chances to win this tournament and
he just few months ago he played here in
warsaw in the world blitz championship
and he shared the first place uh he tied
for the first place with maxima shirley
graph and alireza ferruja and we don't
have maximum and alireza here so
definitely he will be looking for um
winning this event he is playing also
with vishyanant in the first round and i
think this game can be kind of uh
crucial for the for his mood and for his
confidence so we'll see how it will go
what about you christian that is such a
key game the one between duda and
one player that i have my eyes on is the
surging levon aronian and there's
actually three reasons why i'm going to
have my eyes on him the first one is the
american cup an event that finished
three weeks ago in which he actually won
35 raiding points that catapulted him
into the fifth position in the world
standings now the second reason is that
he has a chance to start strong in the
blitz section he will be playing with
the black pieces against the struggling
david gabrielescu and the third reason
why i'm going to pick him is because he
is my overall pick to win the event he
is four points behind vichyanan but
there's 19 rounds to go this one is
going to be an exciting two days guys
how about yourselves who do you have
your eyes set on well thank you
anastasia thank you uh christian i of
course went with wesley so at the very
start i didn't even realize wesley was
number three in the world in blitz i
only know he's really really good
performer in the grand chess horror yeah
he's uh he's become an absolute
powerhouse in the shorter time controls
as well and uh has had a very very uh
good girl a couple of years i think but
as usual uh all the pairings are
extremely legitimate look at them for
this first round of blitz peter yeah uh
in in this first round we have gabriel
lesko on the white side against
uh the two ukrainian players are playing
each other with uh kiroshenko on the
white side of it uh vichy white against
duda our hero game for to this round
yeah i think it's so it's a very clear
choice to start yeah wesley is white
against raleigh wojciech and also very
very interesting pairing there the
bottom uh fabi playing white against
richard rapport rehearse had a fantastic
fantastic rapid event and five had a bit
of a
start to the uh to this tournament but
he has become a very very good uh very
strong blitz player and as my pick for
uh for the winner of the whole thing i
would like for him to
actually start starting
him i've actually played against him in
this jacket it appears to be his like
go-to jacket go to blitz jacket yeah i i
played against him in the uh
riga uh lindoris uh abby blitz that
kiril shashanka won and he also he also
showed up in this and played every
single game now when i'm playing blitz i
want a very loose clothes i'm not going
to go in my suit jacket or i come with
my suit jacket but i immediately take it
off i go for the polo shirt i don't even
like the long sleeve yeah i i i sat down
and i said you're not even taking the
jacket off what disrespect
he said i've been playing the whole
tournament like this okay okay fine
because i want to be loose how about you
alejandro you don't want your clothing
to uh yeah you don't want to be too
stiff and actually i don't know about
this particular term we have the rapid
and blitz here we allow the players to
not be necessarily in their hero's got
the idea
the idea he's got the character he knows
he knows he knows what blitz is about
vichy
got the look dude has got the look i
mean come on come on no no no no suit
and tie for blitz no not for blitz come
on
but we still got his gct jacket radix
got the long sleeves
i actually prefer the jacket over the
tight shirt though oh yeah
because this shirt can really see and i
think you know
we are somewhat serious about this
because if your movement is restricted
it might cost you those fractions of a
second somewhere which might become
decisive and you can multiply it by 60
million exactly and you might be three
seconds but that fabulous thing is uh is
very
very i don't think it restricts him in
any way
now we're going to have any opening uh
yeah
the first one the first the first move
we're expecting to be uh
to be made by lucas turley who is a fido
vice president
a very well-known figure in the polish
and international chess circles and here
he comes yeah
what kind of move does he want e4 says
fishy
give me e4 or give me death
no fun
actually asking the player what they
want to be played i know
just make a move right
be flippant and we're off and we're off
and again
we are aware that there will be five
games in play but because of the nature
of blitz it being so fast
we will focus on a single game
and if this game peters out for whatever
reason peter
then we will swap
that is very very nice and i've
obviously never heard that no i've never
heard that yeah
it's very new and i'm i'm stunned by it
um
uh the answer berlin with g3 bishop c5
and bishop takes c6 is on the board
knight c3 is a move i personally
am somewhat surprised by because it it
feels like it's not really the square
this knife belongs to like you normally
see it developed with g2 and then c4
perhaps
but
i think what rishi wants to do here is
castle queen side and the knight then
in particular perhaps you you can play
uh
g4 and then knight two knight g3 knight
five perhaps some kinds of plans like
this could be uh could be in effect you
could also just keep it on c3 and play
in the center but i think this plan has
become
a lot less popular i i find the move a7
a5 a little surprising
uh alejandro
white wasn't threatening any ever to get
an a3 and b4 or you just gain space on
the queen side i think it's so they just
they just make those moves
why aren't we castle we're not
committing to i think a side to castle
two just played a5
you may go in queenside
i might be if you if white castle's
queenside we might cast a queen inside
and reply okay that's true that's good
probably not the fight castle's king
side but yeah uh but yeah
double queenside castling is very much
on the menu here but yeah bishop takes
e3
this structure
you know you you grow up being taught
that uh
allowing trades which bring your
opponent's pawns closer to the center is
not great but i think the structure has
been by this point understood to be
quite fine for black and also we see an
additional justification for a5 interest
of gains more space on the queen side
there with a5 a4
um
yeah now whitefield castle king side and
uh
we get a kind of a strange maneuvering
uh maneuvering game on our hands here
where uh i very much like knight ta the
knight of six wasn't really doing very
much it will be much better position
than d6 f7 f6 bishop e6 to follow up f7
f5 is playable in some positions but i'd
be reluctant to do it i think we don't
have to i think we just go 96 which b6
f6 we've got a solid yeah we
we are very very solid and in terms of
counter play we could eventually go for
like b5 c5 b4
uh or something like this whereas white
normally yeah as i as i mentioned yeah
white normally starts
uh pushing on the king side as early as
possible but
um
it's not that easy to
without getting something going d4 i
mean if if you keep d4 in a band for
very long and once you've played g4
you're not playing d4 but i think in the
structures you're not really playing g4
anyway because you want your structure
in the center as solid and uh as
untroubled as possible once you play g4
the bishop on c8 starts guessing targets
to pull the targets the pawn on e4 could
become
a bit weak in particular if black is not
obliged to respond to it and black
normally wouldn't be obliged to respond
to it so we just keep
forced to capture yeah we just keep the
pawns on d4 and e5 in place yeah in
place keep that tension and the pawn on
e4 uh becomes a bit vulnerable so yeah
vicious is going for those plans yeah
to my mind i've got a very clear plan if
i'm in vichy's shoes i'm putting i'm
doubling my rooks on the f file i'm
going to try to plant my knight on f5
and essentially i'm hoping that through
piece play only
i'll make no g4g5 might happen
i'm wondering if it actually is a threat
right now for us if you pass here i
don't know you played b6 here well no
obviously
yeah i'm wondering if g5 not is not just
good here because
king h8 though right king h8 steel gfgf
will be playable
well this is actually is what i really
want to try to try to achieve is through
piece play only
i kind of
created a target what yeah
g6 here i'm not sure like it's it's
double edged uh it's double edged
because blackberry i mean i have
blunders knight takes e5 i probably
shouldn't be blundering that takes it
right there
thank you for that i didn't see it but
thank you for that very much preferably
you shouldn't do this good morning lewis
but you know you know what i mean
and i think your point of g5
is so well uh
made
duda said i'm cutting it out completely
forget whoa forget it you're not playing
g5
it may not be a good move but i'm gonna
now i am back to being very interested
in d4 ideas but i guess the knight just
goes to f7 like we can play rook a1 and
that will create a threat of d4 well
threat idea of d4
but when when d3d4 actually happens
black will just play knight f7 or knight
c4 if you're feeling adventurous but
neither seven in particular and keep
everything very very much in place
and
yeah this is another question
bishop played queen g3 very quickly i
thought maybe g3 was a square yeah which
you could have used
for the knight
and he did play rook after i was
wondering about king g2 and rook h1
uh for the moment just trying to open
the age yeah
no he's he's going for the rooks on the
f5
yeah i think i think he wants his pieces
uh
optimized uh and then he will consider
how to try to open things up because
what g5 does is apart from stopping g4
g5 it also stops knight h1n the five
play meaning that
uh in general white uh
has been very very significantly
restricted in terms of what you can even
try to do could i just ask you peter
what would have you what would your uh
initial knee-jerk reaction be to the
move d3 d4 because if you're going to
play d4 i think i want to do it at the
time knight c4 probably
because i have queen d6 there in the end
right if you take place ah
good for you i have queen to six which
wins material yes you do
okay that answers that that was why
that she went with probably brooks
but also in general i think vicious once
again i think he is very very
uninterested in
the idea of d3d4 unless it sort of wins
right because it undermines his
structure such an extent that black's
play uh you know black's counterplay
suddenly becomes very very valid okay
that sure should be made by h6 semi
semi-automatically i would assume like
you don't really
do hesitate yeah you don't really even
spend much time with okay it's
now going to be uh
prepared to go rook fadrock h7 right you
yes the h file will not really be it's
difficult to establish dominance over on
the h file here although if i go rook h2
here i just want to show you a funny
little thing
h2 rook f8 which i think is a huge
mistake yes we can go hghd q in h3
and after rook h7 there is a bit of a
tactical issue yes there is the f8 rook
is hanging yeah ruka fate is basically
actively bed in this position yeah if
there wasn't a rook on a fade this
tactical blow would not have blow would
not have existed exactly but because i
made that horrible move i just lose on
the spot here with black it's good for
you good for you i mean you
allowed us to demonstrate a beautiful
tactic and instead let me just uh let me
read i think this is called an active
blunder in the classification of
blunders basically
your move creating a tactic which wasn't
there until you made it you created it
yourself
yeah is that almost like a uh an own
goal
pretty well yeah i kind of
i'm i'm not even entirely making this up
i saw i saw this classification of
blunders in the book some at some point
in my
in my misspent youth yeah
uh it looks pretty good for vichy's
settings very promising yeah that's
that's 94 and g4 is going to be a
monster
yeah
correctly preparing for it yeah yeah
but it still looks very very threatening
i could even maybe make an argument for
going knight g4 h5
and wesley apparently lost
my goal already
my my pick wesley so number three rated
player in the world has just gone down
on
and around one of the rap apartment
around one of the blitz
um okay i got an i i got a question for
you uh
how about knight g4
and if you play
xf6 i was going to yes that was that was
going to be my suggestion before we okay
heard the breaking news yeah i don't
know how good it is because
you
i get to sometimes yeah you sometimes
struggle to actually land the yeah
exactly like black just runs away but
then you put
yeah it looks very promising to you okay
right right it looks it looks very she
did not go for that he i think i was
told that
it was a rook blunder pardon me i'm just
yeah
wesley wasn't doing that great but he
blundered a full rook in one move
that hurt
yeah uh bishop for now goes rg2 and
queen of three so he wants queen h5 he
wants knight g4 he wants a kind of a
slower build up in the meantime
hitting e4 or hitting e4 or hitting e4
and uh yeah this is now very very
unclear because once once black actually
manages manages to open something up in
the center yeah white no longer has you
know all the freedom in the world to to
push on the king's side
queen b7 is a move i would consider in
this position maybe yeah this is what he
does
so your idea is that if i take on c4
knight queen six queen takes e4 or queen
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no
no
no
yeah it's protected yeah yeah sorry yeah
just ndc played very quickly yeah maybe
uh
i still would like yeah he takes his c4
and now vishal goes back to trying to
give mate on the other side of the board
94.
uh yeah and he i think he will very
happy to go h5 knight xf6 if h5 happens
but he doesn't currently have much of a
threat so yeah young sister very wisely
decides not to not to commit to any
weakening of the structure on the king
side ghost queen b6 kind of hinting at
h5 now still probably not a threat but
at least hinting at it exactly very
interesting very sharp position which i
don't entirely know how to assess
i'll occur completely with that
perspective both
i get the feeling black actually isn't
doing so poorly but
it's so difficult to judge yeah
oh i was about to say imagine i play h5
how are you ever going to get that rook
out of h7
he takes he takes hg he decides decides
probably rook h2 if black uh yeah i
think i think the point you don't leave
the rook on h7 unopposed i think you go
rook h2 yes and try to uh then use the h
file and potentially the d7 square to
generate a very strong attack it takes
king takes
yeah like
i'll and ludo apparently is playing
entirely in increment now whoa he's
really
so vishy's got a a a nice advantage on
the clock uh peter could you comment
yeah it's like 40 40 seconds against
five yeah b2 is hanging in some cases i
don't think we can whoa
we're gonna queen h5 check and like this
wins
hang on a second quick king just seven
queen a king of seven and then he goes
rook g8 and gives him eight on the back
rank i guess yeah just look g8 beautiful
that is a very very nicely spotted shirt
reminds me of that game
for none from the sofia much but
yeah but a much happier 96 do you have
maybe this is a very strong mate how
queen g8
and uh he's gone location there was no
mate after the queen ga but look at this
oh because
queen f8 is wrong that they defend it i
apologize now queen g8 queen f8 is made
into yeah queen dhm8
very very nicely done by the show madras
that's quick that was beautiful but
let's switch to the fobby rapport game
yeah very intense still materials
technically equal
but take a look at that
yeah i think i think fabio was in
trouble earlier but now black black used
to have a very strong bishop it's gone
traded it's gotten traded off and the
the position opened up any other bishop
is just going to be should be known as
there should be five wins at peace here
rook and you're probably rooker wasn't
bad either but bishop b5 i think is just
simpler i mean doesn't win a piece if
you don't play queen five check but then
you are
i would assume not holding this position
no i would have played qnc3 but it
doesn't it shouldn't matter
uh it's a quincy eight kind of strong
yeah
kind of strong and there it is fabi with
a win wow
knox uh
knocks richie
and gabriel resigns us well does he
resign yeah yeah he resigned against
yeah that probably will be a drawn uh
drawn queen ending
no no no no no no no white white wins
first white wins and first yeah anton
yeah unhappy about
things
well let's take a look at what happened
in some of these games
were there any draws by the way no draws
at all in today's games five decisive
trolls that's a draw what is a draw
indeed this was a wild one actually
between uh favi and
richard rapport take a look at what
happened we had this crazy king's indian
you can tell it's a kingston indian none
of the pawns traded we have some tension
in the center and on the king side and
here fabi committed a blunder that
turned out to be a brilliant idea play
the move knight d1
sorry rook d89 d1 and gave away his king
side h takes g4 i don't know if he
forgot that after f takes g4 oh dear
there's knight takes e4 and your
position collapses so he won 91 hg4
knight c3 to defend this fun but
fischer's old idea give the pawns away
and check made your opponent on that
side of the board it's still a valid
plan of course the engines think that
black is better because you're up upon
and whatever but who cares after pawn
takes bishop takes it was clear that
this attack wasn't so easy to repel in a
faster time control actually the
engine's hating taking on f3 and it was
a mess it was a real mess for a long
time
things kind of happened
and we eventually got into this very
very weird end game
in which uh right here in which black's
king's side kind of disappeared this
pawn is passed but this king suddenly
wasn't in such great shape this rook and
the queen making some advances the
bishop is cutting the diagonal this
bishop on f3 would be a great piece if
it rejoins the fight but it can't go to
g4 and through some tactics black took a
pawn
but was forced to defend when queen d7
catching this part of d6 but in a blitz
time control it's not easy to play in
the defensive and it was all the way
down here that richie really started
making his mistakes bishop d4 was not
good knight b5 already both players in
time pressure 19 seconds for favi a
minute for richard and knight b5 hits
this bishop advances the pawn and it
kind of fell apart here after knight
takes c4 because you can see that after
queen takes this pawn is just way more
powerful than black's pieces the king is
safe because the knight has to retreat
and is far away from the king and
eventually you saw how favi converted
this one in the chef checkout game it
was kind of a crazy one uh we had a lot
of mistakes but it really came down to
uh at the very end we're gonna go to
this position
and
here you need to start with the move e4
as black uh you can see that there's a
pin on the rook there's gonna be an
eventual pawn race between this pawn on
c4
and at this pawn on uh that's eventually
gonna be down on e4 but you see this
bishop is blocking this pawn
it needs to move for the pawn to advance
e4 would have equalized in this position
because you queen at the same time as
white but the way that korboff did it
with only 13 seconds on the clock king
f3 it doesn't add up bishop takes king
takes c5 and as you guys saw white spawn
is actually the one that queens first
and that's more than enough for
shivchenko taking down a victory against
his countrymen and we have two more
games that we saw uh our friends in
poland have the action summarized for us
thank you alejandro yes actually i was
having my eyes on the game between gavri
lesko and levon aronian because i felt
like levon is going to go into this
matchup with the black pieces with a
desire to win this game let's see what
happened we started off very well
actually for gallery lescoe he won the
opening phase i have to say he was
blitzing out his moves while levon
aronian is was spending some time so
let's see we got all the way to this
point rook to d1 castle e5 immediately
played by gavri lesko very critical move
in this position knight takes c5 knight
to d7 establishing the pin and regaining
that knight on e5 knight takes f7 well
that's quite an interesting one bishop
takes d4 knight takes d8 bishop takes f2
king to h1 rook takes the eight this was
his preparation gary lesko's preparation
he blissed out every single move while
levon aronian actually only had four
minutes at this point so he spent some
time to get to this position and on his
first thing gabrielescu made a mistake
he was supposed to play this move bishop
to g5 now the whole focus of this
position is to attack the bishop on f2
and attack the pawn on e7 you cannot
allow the bishop from f2 to defend that
pawn on e7 from h4 like it happened in
the game for example after knight to f6
bishop to c4 and this allows white
species to find harmony in the position
rook to d2 targeting the bishop as we
were discussing followed up by rook to
e1 everything comes nicely into the
position and white is going to get a
nice advantage knight to d4 was played
allowing bishop to h4 bishop to c4
knight to e5 once again another critical
moment and right now gabriel lesko if he
would have found rook to d4 immediately
well this would have been quite a
sizeable advantage for the young
romanian because black has to find all
this very difficult moves bishop to f2
rook to f4
rook to f8 or bishop to a7 good luck
finding those type of moves with only
four minutes on the clock
he did not do that knight to e7 and we
got to this position in which in fact
leveronian is the one building the
advantage and let's see what happened we
got to this end game which felt to be
honest very close to equality but levon
aronian he has the experience and he was
able to draw water from the stone root
c2 b3 king comes to the center now white
is a bit passive but he did have a
crucial chance to maintain equality
bishop king to e4 rook to d7 h4
king to e5 and now the critical mistake
g3 he was not supposed to allow the rook
to come to c3 and attack the pawn on a3
which allowed black to transition into a
winning end game unfortunately for him
he played this move g3 and after rook to
c3 it was all over anastasia what game
did you take a look at i was checking
the game a bit actually i think it was
the most dramatic game in the round uh
which happened between wesley saw and
the radical tashiq um after some
theoretical battle in need so they came
to the position and i would like to show
a couple of critical moments here um um
so
let's say after some exchanges in the
center you see that black got this very
nice c5 square for the pieces and um
okay wesley was just trying to put his
rooks on the open files just made some
logical moves uh g3
i mean he just tried to protect against
the check yes so just just remove i mean
and after a6 put his knight on d6 i mean
position looks fine for white and uh
after a couple of moves he proposed the
queen's exchange and um actually vitasha
could just go for this exchange and the
ending would be about the equal after
knight c5 move so he he he decided to
play queen justice
yes
yes sir
and now he played bishop before move and
i had a chance to chat a little bit with
radic and he told me that he completely
missed this move knight f5
which maybe is not so great actually
moved but
on the other hand i mean he said that he
had no idea and he played this rookie
shocking move yes
but he said that he kind of saw that
there are some jumps of the night but he
didn't really um see this knight f5
there were some interesting variations
actually black even can take probably
this night on the five and then after
rook d8 there are some lines with bishop
d1 i don't know i mean what's happening
here i mean rook goes back probably so i
mean but somehow computers so i think
perhaps the the main idea behind this
knight to f5 just to show it to
everybody is that if you do yes of
course yes
yes exactly yes thanks christian of
course 97 was the main idea here and
that's why radik was also impressed with
what was happening but let me just go to
the
to the situation what which happened
after rookie eight
um i mean finally the queens left to the
board and they went to ended up in the
ending and everything went more or less
fine until this moment when um let me
show you like
here or somewhere here yes
rook b3 was played by wesley so and
after knight c1 we can see that simply
he blundered the fork and white just
loses uh rook yeah so what a lucky
victory for radhik watashi i just i
spoke with him now and he told me that
it's nice of course to start what can i
say you said it's nice to start the
tournament with the victory
i'm not expecting a collapse for wesley
so but this is it this is the blitz
section we're going to have a lot more
of this coming your way guys back to you
in the studio thank you anastasia and
thank you christian and here peter is
where we stand after one round of the
blitz yeah
for a second there i thought this must
be a typo because if she won he must
have 16 points no
only one point not anymore yeah only
only one point for a win now but look at
how many of our leaders lost yeah peter
three of our top three out of four of
our leaders lost yeah and this year
obviously uh because of that yes quite a
particularly nice thing to the blitz
because exactly uh and he he won a kind
of a game where things count double to
an extent because he was playing one of
his closest pursuers so absolutely it
was a very very important had a
head-to-head and uh his lead now extends
to uh
two points and our round two uh peter
our appearance
uh in round two
yeah we have uh
uh
judo on the white side against anton
korobov who's not really been having the
best time of it
sorry this is uh
blitz yeah yeah uh this is yes sorry uh
levan is playing white against rapport i
think this is nice
game yeah probably the game to watch uh
rather quiet the shack white against
fabicaruana awesome dude versus wesley
would also be a fantastic game to watch
but we only we can only really pick one
right uh
yeah korov
versus anand is uh
another one there and gabrielescu uh
playing the white pieces again uh
against kyrie oschenko but
a big turn around and i just want to
show it on my board very very quickly
from the first blitz game
who wants no i don't want no stinking
dora said anton anton was in this
position where he was
pinned
and it's all it's going to be a race at
the ponds i wait for the broadcast to
pick up on my my board uh just
two moves later he resigns so right here
if anton had played the move e4 because
it's going to be a race between this
pawn and this pawn the game would like
wrong coffee into the studio yes exactly
king instead he blundered king f3 and
guess what
now uh now i have a i have a snippet
that i would like to show on my computer
can we please bring up the same position
and i will repeat what yes
we've
we've done this twice already i don't
think we need to do it the third time
have we uh yes
[Laughter]
coffee coffee coffee
and for our today's uh promoted item
from the q boutique let me
get
my props in order yeah we had a vinyl
board yeah
for today we are promoting a pin
actually i'm not wearing it right now
sadly um
that actually is on my jacket yes
very very nicely uh
you mod your jacket
limited edition lapel pin featuring the
official logo of the grand chest store
it's a two inch round metal uh die cast
pin
available at cubitik
stl.com
nice very nice i've i've i've always
wanted a modeling job and i mean my
jacket got it it's close enough you know
it's
the producers
preferred your jacket to your modeling
you can you can see why that's a good
point good point uh five out of five uh
alejandro what a great start to the day
but what a crazy
end of results there because it looked
at the end of the rapid that richie
really put so much pressure on vichy he
was down to one point lead over richie
and it was closing with the other
players right duda was now within two
points of vichy and there were a lot of
players creeping up and vishy with this
win
really separates himself because of the
results of the other games five decisive
uh results here vishy comes out clearly
on top not just because of his win
against duda but because of the results
of the other boards now has a pretty
nice lead going into the second round of
the blitz but
so much
so much chess left anything can happen
we know how tricky and how tilting blitz
can be so i'm ready for the next round
no question about it and i think that's
really my fear as uh an elderly chess
player is that vichy who had such a
terrific start would run out of energy
we saw it in the third day of the rapids
he was winning well winning is a strong
word he was better against uh richie he
missed the move d3 maybe tiredness
creeped in he lost that game and richie
narrowed the gap
and now he starts with a win i think
it's very important that he won his
first example and also what i wanted but
i i want to say that
uh
in in most cases you know a point is a
point right but he won a very nice game
against a very strong opponent which i
think was for a blitz game very very
well played right he showed a lot of
interesting strategic ideas when the
time came to calculate he calculated
quickly and cleanly
and i think this this gives him closing
combinations i think this gives them a
lot of confidence there to uh to
continue from there uh so yeah uh both
very well for uh for vichy
and again our heroes game uh to
uh round two will be this one featuring
richie rapport who will be black this
will be our key match-up uh of the five
games we've chosen we don't believe we
don't believe that 26-46 for a second
yeah i was about to say well i mean if
alejandro was parking on a ceiling
richard must be barking on his floor
what's going on here well he did lose a
hundred and ninety points the last time
he was yeah he he he
did yeah he did 190 that's what he
yeah
160 that's
that's not uh that's not a recession
that's a depression
yeah in blitz obviously you get uh you
know the k coefficient is uh
for
using using boring technical terms but
yeah you things get slightly blown up if
you if you have a poor tournament
because your normal calculations get uh
quadrupled quadrupled what happens
alejandra to a player who goes until why
why does somebody
like richie who's such a great player
they start playing uh you know
sorry 60-55
[Applause]
and the first move was made by gunner
bjergsen who is a
european
european chess union deputy president
yeah and a very uh
[Applause]
friendly face somebody with metal
tournaments very often
more known around the chest circles as
the organizer of the reykjavik okay
exactly
[Applause]
i didn't recognize him without a suit on
we have their hasn't actually made the
first movie well kind of preempted the
things a little bit yeah don't do it
gooner go go for f4
never
never never
go for h4 as apparently is the metaname
better than g4
better than g5
the grub attack g4 yes
here we go
and levon
yeah left starts with one g4 now richie
interested in king's indian and he's
sticking to his guns yeah even though
he's getting terrible positions
no
c6 the burn system with a6 and b5 that's
that even gary kasparov used it in a
world championship
game against i wonder if we're supposed
to meet this with f4 and knight of three
now
c6 does to me look like an invitation to
to do four pounds some slightly more
ambitious things but yeah levon goes
with knight f3 transposing into
reasonably well known positions kind of
c6 is not really the main move after b3
no but it always exists like it's it's
never a horrible mistake in the king's
indian to places 7 c6
but also with the bishop already
committed to e3 capturing on d4 now
followed by rookie 8 is an excellent way
to equalize because the bishop on e3
after a future d65 it is a little bit
surprising
a little bit surprising that left went
for this yeah you i i expect he goes
queen c2 now because of three defining
e7 um
gift meet upon
i'm trying to figure out if there are
some tactics there i could try to uh to
go for but maybe not
one
i feel like it's probably still useful
for white to include queen c2 and queen
e7 before we play f3 but uh yeah it just
looks very comfortable for black i'm a
bit surprised that
i think i i'll play it there somehow a
little a little well without one of the
maneuvers
yeah queen c2 queenie's okay let me just
put it on the board in case
okay obviously black's last move is all
about putting pressure on the e pawn
queen c2 defends the e pawn and the
trick
that black is kind of basing his counter
play on is the fact that this bishop on
e3
so you might
try to
pretend yeah these things never really
work out exactly but you might try to
pretend that your your bishop is not
that misplaced or
you might just say go go for it see if
you
go ahead and try to win my pawn
yeah well white is never really worse
but black also generally solves
all of his problems very very
comfortably by the way
uh surprising for me not the move queen
e7 but richard did play knight eight
knight a6 is also quite logical because
you want to attack the pawn on e4 with
with knight c5 and uh yeah rook fee one
played uh obviously the one is very very
interested in the idea of stabilizing
now you go queen e7 i guess i don't know
i don't know what
we've gained here putting the knight out
of a6 yeah we can actually play bishop
one now on knight g4 is very strong no
no we can't we can't
leave the control over the over the g4
square until we've played f3
tactically we don't lose the pawn with
which perform but this is more than
opponent yeah you lose the two bishops
and they're very important
dark square bishop and we have f3 d5 on
the board why the inclusion of knight a6
yeah i'm not sure oh
this is his trick
he wants to recapture on d5 with the
knight
i'm still not sure i like this all that
much let's let's say we go queen b3 here
does he want to take on d5 with two
knights like one and then the other yeah
something like this i there we go bishop
f2
neither four bishop f1 i don't hate it
all that much for why no
it's not compo it looks
i mean little bit but there's the
players might be happy with that whole
game ahead of us i kind of expected more
for black out of this i thought he i
thought
levon had been out
tricked by the way we do have the knight
d5 only we have it
with the knight on b4 capture yeah it
should should lead to the similar
positions there is the option of not
taking on d5 now in playmaker
immediately i don't know if it's
official for our for white too i would
like this because my knight would be
nicely and also the light on f6 is not
that great mainly i think right what
we've achieved is that we've uh we will
ask black to spend something on which
he's done immediately yeah normalizing
normalizing the knight but yeah 97 is a
very logical move it kind of belongs on
c5 v you know potentially
e5 in some cases but i think c5 more
likely i love this move by lavon yeah
this is just kind of clamping down a
little
on the majority
maybe on a good day you get to play a5
as well provoke a6 and then b7 is always
a target a half open file sorry peter no
i agree with every word you said i just
want to say that
arguably the biggest issue richard
currently has is the bishop on c8 where
is it going yeah where do you where do
you put it
so that it does anything you can play
knight c5 bhp
but obviously it never gets traded on e6
white very very happily will uh allow it
to still there it doesn't really do very
much it kind of
is constantly in the way
and uh knight c5 queen e3 bishop fade
played and not
yeah but an indication that something
has gone wrong for black that the bishop
i mean as a grunfeld player you never
move the bishop
i mean just principal you do you do if
you have to but yeah
it's not that enjoyable a5 played as you
correctly said yeah white very much once
upon an a5
and again not only because a6 might be a
threat but once you play a6 black always
h5 and he's allowing white to play the
move a6 because the queen of six can be
the first yeah
queen of six
gotcha okay let's see what oh let me
just refresh my board i'll be right back
um yeah we get to this point where uh
you know vice position looks very nice
but you still need to find a way to uh
to do something
rook 81 looks logical but it's mainly an
improvement move yeah h5h4 i expected
richard to play it i'm not sure if it's
actually a good move but having played
h5 you kind of expect
h4 to follow up queen c1 a slightly
mysterious one but maybe bishop e3
bishop g5 is something that he is eyeing
for the future because the [ __ ] point
of two it looks it looks cute but it
doesn't really do very much that's true
uh and also the queen on b2 wasn't
really doing very much uh king h7 now
would definitely go
oh interesting because i thought
stopping bishop h6 would have been
something that levon would be quite
interested in
he goes bishop c4
um
okay eyeballing eyeballing f7 asking do
you want to kind of overreact and put
something on e6 and then i will play e4
e5
because the e5 square will not be under
control anymore so bishop h6 i think he
needs it he means it with b3 yeah bishop
h6 bishop e3 any trades of bishops
buttresses white's idea
yeah of using his majority on the kings
side
e4 e5 you made a very good point about
this bishop still kind of wondering what
its role might be richard played b5 a b
a b
okay just a second he played what
b6 or b5 b5 excuse me
uh and we already we already have a draw
in the game between anton korogov and
vishyanan so yeah anton played something
solid and vishy never really
got very far yeah
okay uh e5 i'm a bit surprised he played
it this quickly but maybe he didn't see
any particular way
he's taken on c6 first
okay is there some tactics after queen
f6 because this looks like it's sort of
simplifying rehearsed tasks yeah i'm
wondering if you can actually go like
bishop d4 queen c6 printer 4 here
exactly that kind of something yeah you
know in a blitz game you're very drawn
to the idea of just giving away uh
somebody else's pieces right yeah
we can do it he should not yeah he
probably shouldn't it shouldn't work
yeah he goes 94 goes up much more
restrained and then comes h3 yeah but in
general i think if we haven't really
achieved much i don't know why we've
traded the pawn on e4 for the opponent
c6 i'm not maybe to stop b5 but yeah i'm
not i'm not sure i like this last
sequence of moves i think richie's fully
back in the game with this rook
on on the a file actually you know
the king's indian is one of those uh
defenses that when black gets the
initiative he then genuinely has
something else that goes with it
so uh h2h3 g3
there's been there's been a board right
yeah there's been a bunch bunch of moves
made yeah uh and yeah one is now
fighting fighting tooth and nail for
equality
whenever you have to meet h3 with g3 you
don't really have any initiative on the
king side of your own you're not a very
happy camper exactly and he he ended up
having to play queen of four here which
is not a move you make lightly but
with the pawn h3 you kind of do
instinctively want to get the queens off
the board
to minimize the chances of blundering
mate somewhere on g2
yeah he does have a very nice kind of
bunch of pieces in the center so i
suspect he's not doing that poorly but
i'm pretty sure he had a reasonably
large advantage earlier so yeah it
definitely represents
uh
just an improvement for for richard i
was just wondering if if richard wanted
f5 and bishop
h6 or the immediate bishop h6 he went
for the immediate bishop h6
uh drawing white's bishop to this
nonsensical some
but look at the time difference yeah the
one is playing the one was playing on
fumes but he did stabilize reasonably
well and i very much like the idea here
at some point of pushing a 405 provoking
bishop to 84 and then playing with the
bishops against bishop and knight remind
me of the times of the two players
please peter it's like eight seconds
against slightly more than two minutes
with levon having the eight seconds yes
[Music]
now
unfortunately anybody who's played lavon
knows that he's just as dangerous with
no time on its clock as he is this is
a lot of time
this is no guarantee of anything exactly
obviously you would prefer to have the
two minutes
in this situation before and
he did simplify the position quite a bit
so it's uh
not not unreasonable to expect him to be
able to come out of this
but yeah well of course two extra
minutes in a reasonably sharp end game
actually is
not nice i am thinking that if as black
i want the rook i want to send the rook
on an adventure but i don't want to lose
the f7 pawn so before i go adventure
seeking i want to play bishop moves in
king g7 just to secure yeah i don't mind
i don't want it at all i think it's a
good plan yeah if we're looking for
waiting moves i very much like those two
moves yeah yeah and it's not that i i'm
looking for a waiting move i do want to
go adventure hunting uh ideas of knight
d3 check and stuff but i don't want to
do it at the well well he does he
does
he he he wants the adventure
of a knight d3 check
95 uh clearly uh being played
specifically to stop well not stop but
discourage 93 check
attacking
anyway like no no what's the reply no
you can't go
93.99 actually wins a piece i think
full stop yeah you can't go 93 check
here so
uh in the meantime wesley uh has beaten
uh youngsters of duda with the black
pieces very whoa very nice result for
wesley and whoa that was a big big
in a bit of a free fall here at the
start of the blitz i'm thinking richie
is
letting things slip big time yeah yeah
this is now legitimately very good for
livon but he is down to six seconds
which is also down to 31 though so
uh this is not not as critical as it
used to be and yeah why does a pawn up
black had to trade
uh their light square bishop for four or
nine so yeah this is obviously going
quite well for
uh
that that this turnaround has occurred
with virtually no time on his clock that
lavonne has managed to well he's
thinking he's thinking on richie's
richest time and also many of his moves
are kind of
necessary so you
he'll repeat a couple of times okay
richard fails through that's very very
interesting to me because he's not even
ahead on the clock anymore and he uh
you know you don't have an expectation
that levon actually will repeat for the
rest of the game but still repeating a
couple of times in a position where he
clearly wars right would seem you know
wise
no stinking draw yeah rickard disagrees
he he did establish a very nice
blockading position where you you can't
really allow rugby to check
very easily no uh because yeah the
pollen h2 still
still is quite weak for uh for levon
i think so yeah
the one is sort of keeping things under
control but
richard saw that one check
idea okay three i get whoa knight c5
yeah okay this is no trouble for black
because uh right with the rooks coming
off white is a lot freer to try and
there is that h3 pawn that you know
there's three you don't have to take
please don't take yeah you you have to
prepare bishop d3 somehow because the
bishop needs to like in order for white
to win the easiest way to try and win
this position is to get the bishop to f1
but it needs to be prepared and now
you're going to should be three now yeah
and you probably actually no you can't
buy it i was going to say you have to
bite the bull take on the three play
bishop c5 but the pawn ending is
completely lost
uh
bishop takes b6 ooh one second bishop no
he did it the wrong way he had to go
bishop to d6 to be able to hit h2
oh now the bishop is just
you could be 56 now take on eight oh but
now it's too late the pawn on h3
this is objectively lost but yes in a
blitz game
with no time anything can happen even
though like it's so easy to play with
the bishops that you expect even in a
blitz game that simply through like
though
the volume of moves made like eventually
something drops because
it's just so easy so much easier to play
whoa whoa whoa he should have gone king
to g3 i don't think so and just hang
around i'm keeping i'm keeping my king
as close to the to the f pawn as
possible i i
on there i disagree with you yesterday
yeah
king on g3 would have been keeping the
king close to your f pawn
oh
three four is actually a concession
because now black can yeah exactly like
you go king is seven and you try to you
can even maybe consider playing knight
e6 takes takes must be five maybe wins
maybe it doesn't yeah you kind of have
the immediate hp5 is even stronger here
that's right that's a very nice thing oh
and richard's got no time on his clock
but now it collapses i think right wow
yeah now it collapses now it collapses
that's the king
and sonia there's just no counterplay
anymore yeah yes this is dead that lost
him
yeah oh
oh oh uh
lavon turning things around with no time
on his clock do we have a remaining game
no that was that was the last game of
the round and uh seems like five
five one so five is on a bit of a roll
i'm
very happy to report alejandro
what happened in the other games we were
just mesmerized by this one that was a
great fight between the game between
korabov and vichy the leader of the
tournament not much happened we had a
tarash type structure and after a bunch
of trades we got to this position in
which
white has pretty much everything the
safer king better major pieces but black
is up upon and in this kind of positions
you do have compensation for the pawn as
white but it's just enough for the pawn
and not more than that after queen d7
you could try to take on b17 but easier
give up your entire queen side for the
pawn on
a three and three versus three nothing
happened in this game meanwhile
oh no what happened here
what a disaster i was just about to say
how gabrielescu won this game
what happened in this position because i
left it off
around here in this position and i was
thinking
win
gabriel is about i was just writing my
speech what's up on how gabrieleska won
his first game of the tournament
but
i guess not something happened well two
pawns extra here for white advancing on
the queen side but after b4 kingd5 was
apparently a little bit better but
knight takes h4 knight e3
bishop d6 he made a huge blunder with
bishop e1 he needs to keep pushing the
guys knight d5 also makes sense just to
hold on to the power on f4 and make
black span a couple of tempe instead of
bishop e1 was a big mistake because
after knight f3 actually there's no
there's no good spot for the bishop you
have to go back and f4 is now hanging
that gave up two huge tempe for
uh black to try to solidify his position
i just still think after king d4 there's
some chances but this kind of finished
again because after knight d3 your
knights are hopping around and it's not
enough time to actually win the game
because this end game is actually drawn
the h pawn is just about enough counter
play big miss for gabriel
he outplayed his younger opponent
shevchenko the entire game tricked him
as well but wasn't able to convert let's
go to poland as we have the
games the two very important games as
fabiano carona and wesley saw won their
matches
such a huge miss that was for gallery
lesco but let's take a look at what
happened in the important matchup
between voytack and caruana because as
peter was mentioning caruana right now
is on a roll two victories in the first
two rounds here in the blitz section
let's see how that happened d4 knight to
f6 c4 d6 an early d6 now what's the idea
of this early d6 for example if you go
for knight to c3 i'm going to respond
with e5 and this uh transposes into some
very awkward king's indian type setups
because also i don't have to go g6
bishop to g7 occasionally i can go
bishop to e7 first so voitasha wanted to
avoid that he played the move knight to
f3 g6 knight to c3 but now it's too late
because black has the option of playing
the move bishop to f5 and stop white
from playing e4 now it's very
interesting uh strategy coming from
caruana we know caruana he doesn't
generally play this he usually plays the
names maybe some d5 on move number one
definitely not this one this type of
setup maybe he's recycling some teenage
year uh openings who knows like richie
report was mentioning that he's doing d5
immediately followed by e5 and i have to
say it did feel like voitachet was
building up the pressure quite nicely
and uh in fact at this point if we look
in the database the top two games are
fabiano caruana from 2013 and 2014. long
long time ago now let's see what
happened bishop uh to d7 e4
and now we got to this critical position
and i have to say i was really impressed
with
how voitacek is keeping control of a
decision not allowing any breaks in the
center with c6 and d5 or b5 for black so
nice control by white rook to e1
building up nicely the advantage
obviously white has more space so
therefore supposedly he's better at this
point a3
b4
kick the knight away knight to d7 f4
finally time to grab even more space
queen to h4 rook to e3 knight to f6
queen to d4 and this is a critical
moment after this move bishop to b7 what
white had to understand is that black
has a clear threat this bishop to b7 a
quite innocuous retreat it doesn't seem
like it's threatening anything but in
fact it has a huge threat vojtech had
the right plan he understood that he
needs to focus on the queen on h4 try to
trap it with the move bishop to d1
unfortunately this allows the break with
c5 instead of that he was supposed to
play b5 now c5 never happens on the
board because i'm going to amp asante
you and after that you're going to be in
trouble b5 would have kept the advantage
in white's court unfortunately after
bishop to d1 it is black who has the
advantage fabiano looked at him and he
said i am the captain now queen to d6
followed by knight to e4 knight takes e4
bishop takes c4 bishop to f3 another
critical moment but i have to say this
was a very difficult find for fabiano he
played the move rook to e6 very normal
looking move bishop to f3 was in fact
the right move after rook takes f3 rook
to e1 i'm getting ready to put a lot of
pressure on the first rank with rook a
to a1 now for example if you just simply
take on a c5 i will follow it up not
with rook to a1 but in fact with rook to
d8 now i'm going to force your queen off
this file rook to d1 and after king to
g1 rook to d2 check this subtle move i'm
threatening queen to g4 with mating
threats and there's actually no good way
to defend against that this would have
given fabiano the clear advantage he
allowed voyager back into the game let's
speed things up into this end game at
this point i thought okay this game is
going to be over very soon and it's
going to end in a draw no no no fabiano
said let's uh continue playing at this
point rook to d3 big mistake c5 was
critical taking advantage of the fact
that the king on g8 is not yet defending
the pawn on g6 and i can get my rook
behind the pawns you know in end games
you have to get the rook behind the
pawns this would have allowed white to
have full compensation for the pawn and
probably the game would have finished in
a draw fast forward a few moves and at
this point king 24 allowed black to
penetrate on the second rank with rook
to c2 followed by rook to e2 and this
was all she wrote because with six
second on the clock and four rooks on
the board you're not going to be able to
defend this end game as white and in
fact it happened fabiano caruana won his
second game in a row and he's getting
close uh to the leading position uh what
about you anastasia what game did you
have your eyes on yeah and i think karan
is very into they catches uh t-shirt
maybe it gives him brings him some luck
right so we can check the game between
wesley duda and wesley so you will
remember that wesley lost this crazy
game the previous round
just missing his rook but this game was
actually pretty tense and we can analyze
it forever actually because it was was
it started
quite quietly but then the critical
moment came on the move uh 11 when uh
dude i decided to play actively and play
what's the progressive approach yes
trying to actually show that he would
like to attack on the king side while
his opponent can try something on the
queen side so it's opposite castling
like a typical position uh happened but
wesley actually took it very seriously
he first defended his king side and then
after a few moves he actually
blocked those pawns after age four he
went for bishop d4 making sure that the
pawns might not go any further and uh
okay white has to protect the knight and
after that bishop h5 and now it's black
who will start his attack
on the queen's side
to move forward exactly yes and so
actually now actually black is doing
quite fine and we know with this
opposite castling tempest are very
important you have to play very fast and
this is what started he started to move
forward his pawns trying to open the
files uh everything went was logical uh
duda was still insisting there is some
kind of attack on the on the king side
he came out with a nice plan moving his
knight on h3 trying to push a four
so this is what happened actually in the
game but look how wesley actually um
protect combined the two things
protecting his king side and at the same
time trying to do something on the queen
side and he managed actually to push
forward his pawns well he's coming fast
yes he's going to open up the king side
that's going to be all she wrote for the
white king yeah i'm telling you every
move we can last forever because let's
say on every move they had different um
you know alternatives and actually
computer goes crazy here i mean given
different evaluation on each move so
after 96 so also like an interesting
move here i mean maybe it was another
critical moment i mean white actually
doesn't have that many
choices you know you have to find a way
how to stop
pieces coming to the queen's side so he
took played move before which seems to
be logical um it's interesting that
maybe b takes a four which looks strange
maybe it was a better option and then
something like c3 and trying to play
kingston moving his pieces back to way
one yes i mean maybe it was the best one
even though it's still unclear you know
with this kind of attacks you never know
maybe actually i can already see someone
yeah let's see if i can take i take and
then maybe i checkmate you with rook 281
and that mystery
really crazy position it's i'm sure well
spectators had lots of fun watching it
and um i just want to show you
what another critical moment like after
okay one fight of course uh young
christoph understood that his king is in
danger and he's trying to bring his
pieces back to the queen side so after a
couple of exchanges what happened is
he's still trying to defend his pawn on
before he played rook a4 move knight d4
followed you know knight c4 and and
actually believe it or not knight c4 is
the best move in this position there is
no way to protect against this crazy
idea queen c6 threatening mate i mean
some checks on c2 and the rook on a4 so
actually that was a big threat but
unfortunately for dude after knight c4
there was a queen d7 you see winning the
one of those pieces yeah
double attack yes nice double deck
very nice well that was a really nice
yeah and after that yesterday it was
already over for duda who still tried to
move with his king and but he didn't
wesley is back yes with a victory let's
see what happens in the next round back
to you guys in the studio
thank you christian and anastasia and
here we see it
after two rounds of blitz uh from the
start as we came into today vishy
richard wesley lavonne
uh
well no actually it was duda
who was in
third when we started but now the blitz
speeder has turned things around a bit a
little bit yeah and in particular
youngster fell from his uh
position i mean he still died for third
but he was unclear third he has been
caught by uh by two players
uh after losing his first two games
and he did have a strong opponents but
that's going to be
very true for every single round and as
christian said at the top of the show
lavon ironian have won uh
certain rating points uh coming into the
blitz and uh our pairings for the third
round peter uh
in this round we have kiran shivchenko
with white against lemon ironian vishy
uh white against gabrielesko a very
promising pairing for him
wesley plays against anton korobov
fabi is white against duda and let's
make that our heroes game yeah i think i
think this is the one we'll be watching
and richard rapport is white against
radicality who had his very very uh good
position just now against fabi but ended
up losing
yeah
and there you see david uh i think for
david i mean again you know he's been
thrown to the walls
uh he's he's
his positions he he plays very well he
plays well yeah it's it's and then he
kind of just yeah it fades at a certain
critical moment or two and it can be so
costly alejandro when you know you
you're playing well but one slip two
slips three slips and then
i don't know it's the game's over it's a
very streaky type of chess as we've seen
and
it's tough right duda here has a huge
pairing
i think because losing two in a row yep
man that's hard but accumulating losses
in blitz is very easy yeah it is
extremely easy and he's up against a key
a arrival uh as well and that is so with
his 26.46 right yeah that is every time
every time we're going to be looking at
that we'll be
uh we'll be you know it'll be funny too
funny for words yeah
but okay once again for our round three
blitz
uh we're in we're going with bobby
versus dude yeah we have to i think so
yeah yeah that's uh that's the one to
look out for for fabi
uh
a 2-0 start in the blitz is just what
the doctor
ordered alejandro i mean
he
he he wants to
improve his blitz and rapid play well i
mean he's only one point away from a
third right now yeah so he he knows that
for himself this is an important game as
well
it's a candidate's match-up game if you
will it's a candidate's match-up game
and he also starts looking at the
possibilities that if he wins one more
game he's
within striking distance of the leaders
or he becomes one of the leaders dude he
has 12 points foul be 11. right it'd be
nice to
catch him so to speak absolutely
and for wesley at a tipsy
topsy-turvy uh beginning he blundered a
rook against rajcik but he's coming back
he bounced back against duda that's a
big one here for wesley
and with white against anton yeah hoping
for uh further success but once again
we're gonna stick with our hero game of
fabi versus duda as they are underway
and it's the berlin now bishop takes c6
it's probably not the pure berlin but
we'll see yeah yeah i thought we might
actually play uh play for the for the
actual brilliant the ending yeah because
he's he's been one of the people who
actually has been testing it properly
yeah and i just want to say that we we
mentioned that uh
duda had a bit of a fall fall from grace
there starting from zero out of two
same applies to reheard
rihard also lost the first two games as
if if my
note keeping is is accurate is accurate
which i think it is yeah so uh two of
our
uh
you know potential front runners uh in
in the chase in the chase after after
vichy have started really really poorly
one of the remarkable things for me
peter about this whole berlin ending
is that
it it is one of those
that
there's such a great an enormous
flexibility of of plans for black he can
go h5 h4 or you can go
bishop e7 knight h4 trading the knights
uh in one way
the seven king c86 king b7 used to be a
thing exactly world championship matches
almost almost never see it again
anymore i mean but it it definitely used
to be a thing and then a5 beef
bishop before i mean there's just
so many uh
it is it is a very very rich uh rich end
game uh you know it saddens me to say
that but it is actually a very
interesting position it's just that i
don't understand it at all and would
like i would like never to actually have
to discuss it because
i feel like a complete idiot trying to
explain the plans and
you know things
things in general but i was once at
a party at rexingfield's home and he had
this beautiful chess set
and we were playing over a berlin ending
position
and i was showing rex the various
plans and hikaru nakamura was standing
over very very interested spectator he
went through it all
and
wow said rex thank you so much for the
lesson yes sir and and hikaru said to
rex
everything yasser just said was wrong
i don't
hate that
yeah that's that's how i feel when i
when i have to talk about
actually was trying to figure out what
this end game was this one that we're
going to say
yeah if if white manages to double the
rook on the g5 you can check me yeah
it's it's surprisingly difficult to me
but specifically here black will play
for h6 and g5
kicking the the bishop away from that
diagonal or perhaps even h5 as well the
h5 is also a very comfortable way of
dealing
with the bishop and i think king h2 has
been played which is an indication that
h5 king g3 will not actually deal with
the bishop so you have to play h6 but
then five people play a four and once
again you don't
don't have a iron cast way of uh kicking
that bishop away from the all-important
diagonal and of course you cannot castle
we understand you can play king 76 but
that leads to a four or five problems i
assume so black tries to shut down the
d-file and say no checkmates but by
maintaining the bishop on d5 yeah and
currently b three c four or three by b
five i missed probably b5 you can also
throw in a5 a4 somewhere but i think
yeah b5 is probably the more the more
topical thing
and now we really want to solidify the
bishop on d5 as much as possible which
is why i like playing a4 and b5 and then
pushing the king on d7 and saying we can
find yeah we can hide it behind the
bishop on d5 as long as we've stopped c3
c4 from happening right and i think if
we put the pawns on a4 and b5 we
probably do stop c4 from happening quite
quite
for quite some time yes and if you put
your pawn on c6 on c4
then you absolutely absolutely but the
reason why i might want to play c6 and
c5
is because sometimes the king
weirdly if you can get the king 36 it's
the the absolute ideal scenario but uh
you generally don't have time for that
but
maybe in some in some ideal world there
we go i think i think we go rogue d1
here uh i think allowing c5 king c6
would be
uh
strange yeah i i don't know why you
would allow that okay rook
rook d1
f5 gets gets played instantly and then
we think and then we
i am kind of drawn to the idea it's
wrong but i'm very drawn to the idea of
e6 check fe f6 trying to generate a
passer on the g-file i don't think it's
wrong i think that that's really one of
the very standard pawn breakthrough
tactics that i've seen i would still
throw in rook 81 and b5 but it doesn't
really matter that much because i've
seen so often times that this g-pawn as
a passer
it's really good and this e-pawn is
actually not so good i should disconnect
the bishop on d5 from the g8 square i
still feel that
you're probably not winning that
position but it definitely is one of the
strategic plans you can go for sorry i'm
just going to have to refresh my board
sometimes when i play around too much
with these the variations uh
the actual game becomes a sub-variation
and i hate that so rook sorry we
you're right uh rook d1b5 instantly
played rookie 80 obviously we've created
the threat of e5 with e6 with our
previous move and that should not be
allowed by black um and now at some
point we probably will have to play a2
a3 completely killing off our queen side
but also stopping any kind of counter
play
and the king will drop back to c8 is
he's playing b3 no
oh sorry excuse me
i thought i made no noise
yeah that was actually fiber's choice
which surprises me a little bit i guess
he plays before and gets a slightly
better version like you still have no
brakes on the queen side
but your pawns look a little bit less
silly if you play b3 before here unless
he has some tactics which he is looking
forward to but i don't see 100 sure i
want my pawn on b4 not necessarily on b2
the problem is maybe slightly slightly
vulnerable right no you get to play c5
and and make a candidate
whoa
completely different yeah he disagrees
with the entire thing and goes c4 i
wonder what the follow-up is everything
you said
was wrong
i began by saying
every time i talk about the burden i
feel like an idiot and
here we go i mean right honestly this
just confuses me i don't understand this
i don't get it either
the king will come very quickly
back to d7 i assume
now that there's
probably shouldn't lose but yeah i don't
quite know why we gave up we gave up
that pawn and
the only thing i can imagine you still
have hopes
of that pawn breakthrough idea that you
mentioned peter but
what i will say is that we definitely
did not choose the right game for the
game
because there is an absolutely insane
kings let's do it let's do it where do
we want to go
yeah
wesley against uh anton is very
interesting uh
rappard against vojtech is also going to
be a huge mess okay but we have we have
this position and like that's much more
definitely more exciting than our berlin
game exactly okay we're gonna stay we're
we're we're mixing it up here folks
sorry we're going to the game between
wesley
and korobo and anton korobov now if we
can ever get anton for an interview i
mean yeah during blitz tournament you
probably don't get very many interviews
in between rounds but yeah okay what is
going on
up and has a passer on the a file
everything else about whether their
position is blowed up horrible but an
extra pawn on the a file it sounds
pretty well though it's not nothing yeah
you got a fast spawn and it's extra
i mean okay he's kind of control white's
kind of controlling the jumping of this
knight
and of course the pawn is now on pre
yeah you would like to play bishop maybe
you still actually play bishop because
uh after the sixth check i can move the
king somewhere and maybe pick up that
pawn little next move exactly i don't
really like the idea of giving up a3 for
nothing
maybe he goes through
no no no no no no no that's my muslim
he's got knight b8 which is a move
which is a move i really really kind of
dislike on general grouse
it's a pawn he wants to defend his pawn
can't blame a guy for wanting to keep
his pawn intact
uh oh we got uh
alejandro is alejandro
somewhere distress we don't know what
uh oh
and yeah we should actually blunder the
full piece quickly she might be in
trouble yeah this is dead lost against
gabrielesku
whoa
i'm sorry i turned him at leader we
might we've got to go to vichy
where am i going peter
right up
there
yeah he he
missed something
french defense by the way this is a very
topical variation in which white
generally is
such a cute little tactic and uh
oh my goodness knight just has no good
squares queen c4 loses a full piece
because you then have to play rook a3
and after mission before you have to
resign so he just resigns here yeah from
the board
and david what a way to get your first
win
from uh
from the holiest to the lowliest
look at this david with a huge
win over our tournament leader let's
jump back to the game of wesley so yeah
wesley leslie looks looks like a
very promising position but the a pawn
still runs so it's not it's not as
obvious what's going on he's sacrificed
by wesley he played rook as the seventh
and look at what he's doing now yeah uh
horrendous things on the seventh round
he's created a lot of threats along the
seventh round but there is a pawn on a2
so
after okay one i'm rugby 8 i guess is
quite strong right rook b8 i want to
play knight takes b7 and let you queen
yeah well then you you don't actually
have good decisions
i want to do it anyway
he's played knight bc this is very cute
by wesley he actually allowed the queen
and played knight c6 attacking the
bishop with seven still with a check so
in case of rook a7
i get to take one piece and then
take c7 is a kind of a bailout i wanted
e5 before but he is on five seconds two
seconds one dollars on time he did lose
on time
[Music]
and a big smile from wesley so as he
happily takes the point i hate to win on
the game on time but i'll take it let's
jump quickly to the remaining game where
would you like to go
uh lavone yeah uh levon's position is
very dry uh
oh that's actually i don't know which
one to choose yeah let's go with levon
yeah uh levon is uh
i think he's very very level now against
kira yeah against kiriel kirill has
eight seconds left but it's a simple
position to play in general i think he
should be he should be fine uh normally
i think there's much more interesting
juice going on in the game between
richie and uh
and rather yeah that's that's a sharper
end game we have to choose an end game
that's a sharper let's go there for just
a moment yeah oh this yeah let's let's
keep we we can return to our berlin yeah
because it's uh
sort of closer to the
uh fight for the tournament lead and
fight we finally did create that passer
that we were talking about he played
uh
shifted it to one one file
towards the center but the f6 fe six uh
so e6f takes e6 and f6 did happen i was
expecting a g pawn
but it is actually an f yeah it's uh
objectively has to be a very very level
position because you have the the extra
pawn the double decks upon the c file
shouldn't really be
much of a factor who's going to get the
rook and bishop versus rook
don't don't
yeah
in the game between duda and fabi they
both might about what players are
playing for the broken bishop versus
rook advantage yeah why do you have to
say those words yeah are you we will now
we will now have that and i'm pretty
sure we will not have that end game and
commentators curse peter and uh
superstitious
yeah
writing's on the wall now
yeah and in the meantime lev i think
will actually win his game against carol
he's making tremendous strides there
not winning immediately but looks like
he will eventually convert this into a
full point
um all right we'll stay with this one
because it's still so important
for our tournament standings
and roddick i think is
kind of winning against uh yeah erratic
is winning against rockport a huge
blunder in the last minute which
continues a really really horrible start
to the day for for richard
yeah now we can play f7 with a draw
right here we can just play f7 and the
king gets to the c6 pawn in time exactly
yeah he decides not to but like really
at some point you kind of i'm supposed
to our support yeah just go just go f7
here just calculate it once and
yeah he's done it
just just do this and yeah i don't think
no more conditions i wonder if dude
actually keeps the rook song
if you want to flag here you want to
keep the rooks on but yeah i think
bishop takes c3 or even king d6 yeah
right that's actually
kind of stylistically bad bishop takes
e3 was the
statistic
yeah
there we go richard rapport is currently
down a rook i guess that's what's wrong
with this position yeah that work on b2
doesn't have a counterpart
yeah he's he's down he he will
potentially maybe win it back but yeah
the pawn ending is completely and
utterly lost so yeah you just kind of
resign here
uh
yeah 95 kingdom six you don't save these
positions
93. yeah if all else fails we just go
king c5 king g4 and we win yeah or or
93 95 white wins now
he
and this is a famous end game by the way
this is a very very famous end game i
was shocked yeah when this came out all
of us all of us
at some point in our lives have been
shocked by the following knowledge yeah
this is an easy draw
well but for for a computer for a
computer for a computer this is a very
easy draw apparently two pawns down and
the queen and specifically g and h or a
and b versus versus the king in the
corner is
very very confident i had studied queen
and pawn endings and i was studying them
to the point where
what's a winning ending with a queen and
a pawn versus queen and then it was a a
an article in new in chess i think it
was by john nunn
how two pawns make an easy draw and i
was just like no no
no that can't be true
yeah i keep on i keep on referring back
to that story every time this end game
comes up but my
very first very very yeah that's not the
move i would ever have heard yeah but
he's very brave yeah he just doesn't
care uh
i i it almost feels like a three mo
three times
you can't claim you you know you don't
remember you don't remember you you're
never sure about your threefolds yeah
like my very first very strong uh junior
tournament was the uh
soviet juniors under 18 and 89 i want to
say
okay and the closing ceremony was
postponed because alisa galamo was
defending this end game against
victor balagun
and i think she actually drew it wow
or possibly she was pushing as a
stronger side i can't remember who was
the stronger side but basically the
entire tournament was sitting there on
hold kind of snickering saying like why
is this game still continuing you know
that's completely resignable and he was
being blamed out and then potentially it
wasn't one and we were all kind of
laughing
and uh it's just a draw
yeah and everybody's absolutely quick
king g5 if you have no checks anymore
but you put yeah he's been doing it
correctly he's been putting the putting
the queen on yeah exactly on the long
diagonal it cannot be traded with the
king on g5 like there are no checks
which offer a queen trade
so he's been actually holding it very
very comfortably up until
very very nicely done but yeah now the
critical point comes when the king sort
of comes in and yeah i don't like king
chief i like king e3 better by the way
i guess has not only been sterling but
his speed of play he's been outstanding
yeah that's that's his home like he's
just a very very strong blitz player
he keeps on pushing king on h3 it's just
so scary to me okay
g5 yeah founder founder found a way to
play g5 i don't know if that actually
improves it enough but that's definitely
doesn't yeah yeah but like in human
terms you get
more scared of course if this happens of
course yeah actually the engine thinks
it's winning now somehow yeah he could
have played h3 i think 22 and h3 in the
checks with the queen on b7 the checks
actually stop i think there was a moment
there you can also play yeah
why did he allow queen g2 jack
oh this is an immediate perpetual that's
what this is this one this might be an
immediate perpetual now queen d7 and it
checks from behind looks like an
immediate perpetual yeah oh draw
stalemate green h3 oh no
no
[Laughter]
oh
what what that is such a funny position
so he's done so well well to get this
with your move 125 by the way guys 100
and 20 the typical 125th mistake right i
hate that he has one move that draws
checkmate being threatened he has to
play queen d2 expel the king with the
move queen h2 following up he finds this
really nice trick queen h3 check if you
take my queen that's it stale mate but
the king goes to f4 and the sad thing
for white is that you cannot trade goes
into a lost pawn end game if you play
queen down the diagonal shafshanko
realizes quinji for check threatens the
king and the queen at the same time that
forces the trade because there will be
no stalemates on h1 the queen doesn't
hold on to the h2 square and that's all
she wrote this is a dead lost and queen
h3 such a pretty trick but it's white
that ends up tricking himself levon with
a huge win in this one guys
and
let's go to the ritchie game where
richie is
hesitates hesitates hesitates king c8
oh my god
you're down
how is that i can get him objectively
i think it might be a draw now
let's jump to warsaw and get
a first-hand account of what just
happened
thank you thank you sir well you guys
actually uh focused on at the end of
that crucial game between vichyanan the
leader of the event and gavriel but
let's see how they got to that position
that completely lost position for anand
and if you want to get your first
victory in the tournament you might as
well do it against vichyanan what a
great moment for the young romanian e4
e6 one thing i can tell you about david
is that he knows his theory so let's see
they actually played 20 moves of theory
i'm going super fast through the opening
phase because there's absolutely nothing
to look at everybody knows this line at
their level right now bishop to d7 rook
to b3 queen to e7 and we get this check
to provoke the move g3 critical moment
at this point after queen to d4 a very
classy move by david gravilasku which he
by the way knew because he played it
instantaneously he played the move
bishop to a3 the idea behind it is if
you go bishop to e7 now what i can do is
either go castle or the move f5 the
point is that as black you have to go
rook to c8 and try to exchange the rooks
unfortunately without the extra square
on e7 for the queen now i can just
simply go rook to b7 or rook to c6 and
you're going to lose your queen so quite
a nice move bishop to a3 very very
classy but he knew it and after that
castle rook to c8 rook takes c8 and we
got to this position in which it does
seem like the harmony of black species
is just overpowering queen to e3 queen
to c4 everything gets activated for
black rook to b3 bishop to b4 and this
was the last moment in which vichy could
have stayed in the game with the move
rook to b4 followed by bishop to c5
instead of that he forgot about this
crude
critical move excuse me bishop to a5
what an explosive shot for david
gavrilasku you cannot take on c4 because
actually i'm going to take back on c4
now you have to defend two pieces with
your rook and that's impossible losing
the game with the white pieces vishyanan
huge victory for gallery lesko so
just david when he came out from the
playing hall he was so happy and he said
but he said actually that just maybe she
mixed some theory and he didn't know one
move so but he was still so happy after
that game i also chatted with wesley so
who said that he was laughing after the
game uh even in the playing hall because
his opponent
corabov he lost some time and not only
that but he was making his moves very
very slowly and this is not the way you
should play blitz yes you have to be
faster and what happened in this one
between shivchenko and eronia yeah this
game okay started quite peacefully i
mean it was uh
long long theory which both players
probably knew because 11 also plays this
with white pieces and let's say
yeah they they came to this um
position which was pretty
equal and i think we could check the
moment where he played the last more or
less mistake at this moment i mean the
ending he played a four instead of this
he could have tried queen e4 trying to
give a perpetual check and save the game
because black pawns are very dangerous
right with moves like queen a8 or queen
if e8 um so for example if black pushes
the pawn you simply go there then you
can you can just basically give
perpetual and that's going to finish the
game
thank you anastasia and you guys
actually saw the ending of this game as
we are getting ready for the next round
we're going to go to a commercial break
stay tuned we'll be back shortly
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage peter after three
incredibly eventful of blitz games i
don't even know how to call them uh we
have a shake-up at the leaderboard yeah
and as you can see vichy has actually
increased
his lead
honestly he's been having kind of a
mess start start to
uh to the event he
won a very nice game in round one and
drew a very uneventful game against
anton korobov who is not one of the
front runners and then lost to
gabrielle's couple with white piece and
twenty ishmael right and two increases
yeah and his lead went from one point to
two and a half because richard rapport
who was behind him coming into the days
uh no points so far zero from three why
a very surging lavon aronian is saying
hey guys can i join the party yeah let's
crash the party yeah lev is on a hundred
percent so far and five years on two and
a half out of three and look what we've
got coming up yeah uh levon is uh white
against radic uh do the plays against
richard rapport who continues losing for
for today no points so far cora both
caruana gorillas
saw and the young ukrainian killed
is playing against the show
give me your heroes game because out of
these five games it's not that easy i'm
picking dude versus uh robert a board
number two let's do it dude versus
report we'll keep an eye on this game
and again
uh alejandro keep us on our toes if this
game stay sours or stale uh oh it's ours
still watch it if it's tails we won't
uh tell us where we keep an eye oh well
look at this
a very very rare guess but yeah richard
can play everything
yeah i think he's perfectly capable of
playing absolutely everything and also
this perhaps is a bit of a signal of
varusian's favorite way of meeting the
bononi by the way he loves these early
bishop f4 variations i think you're
supposed to play queen e7 instead of
bishop g7 but i'm not 100 certain i
think you were kind of
maybe it's not here i i remember we were
we being uh we being tim kramnik uh
because uh in in round in in game 13 of
the march in bristol against uh peter
like
oh yeah uh vlad played the bannon
because by that point he you know
obviously
uh just equalizing with black was no
longer really uh something that was very
uh exciting and he actually did get a
winning position in the game and uh wow
some very very complicated end game
where he failed to to find a somewhat
uh study-like
way to convert it into a full point and
i think he played queen e73 bishop g7
but we get a very similar position
anyway since
uh do the declines to play to e4 does it
make sense to go hog wild on the king
side for black with moves like f5 g5 i
expect it eventually uh because i don't
think we can allow yeah you can't afford
to
give white a chance to just kick this
knight away back to d7 is a horrible
square for it f7 slightly better uh
because you control the pawn and d6 a
bit funny you say slightly i say
significantly because from f7 somehow i
mean the knight you know recovers a lot
of squares
and by leaving the d7 square open for
the bishop it's kind of easier it
supports this play as well yeah you know
yeah exactly protect the b5 square um
i don't know but for me this is just i
love this type of chess i like what i
call the battle of ideas and how would
you evaluate the position
take a side which one which side would
you prefer peter generally in positions
like this i kind of like black simply
because uh you know it feels to me that
this is what i've played the binoni for
okay this is about the maximum i could
expect out of a binoni a very playable
very unclear position
and because of that you know
whenever you you feel like you've gotten
the maximum it feels like you you should
like your position i suspect you
probably shouldn't actually
i suspect despite seemingly having
gotten the maximum you're still wars
because these guys and i very much like
you know the instant way uh young chest
of replies on ib5 with knight a4 not
allowing any kind of trades and also
yeah this pair of knights on b6 and c4
just does such a good job of controlling
everything and eventually yeah some kind
of queen g2 bishop f3 uh and then
uh i will play one day for e4 i don't
want to do it too early you could also
you could also play for b4 in this type
of position even though it doesn't
really create such a threat because i
think black maybe would even welcome
bake c5 gtx e5 getting the g6 square for
them for the for both of the knights
yeah okay this is i think
the larger problem the larger problem
for black is that i have no idea what
i'm doing
you're reacting yeah
g5 g5 seems yeah and g4 perhaps he i
don't think he wants to open the king
side necessarily with the move g4 i
think he probably wants to kill the
position entirely off by playing g5 h4
and then
once we've really made sure black will
never have a single move in that game
ever again then we'll play for therefore
then we can choose yeah which way we
will open the position up for for the
future i kind of like this though for
white in the sense that i'm not just
gaining space i am starting to consider
well that as well yeah
and that's why the knight i think sevens
i think knight h6 really does beg for g5
and h4 right i think now we definitely
do it
h5 h4 h4 and yeah we can eventually
maybe even play for an attack on the
king side because of just how few
squares black has for any of their
any of their pieces but
yeah it's just a very very nice uh
setup for white web yeah i just don't
understand where the counter play is
going to come from well
that's why we call it bononi the son of
sorrow you you achieve your ideal as
black and it's not the greatest
achievement
not very happy story of my life
you're at the apex
uh the knight on b5 by the way i mean
it's pretty it's doing nothing it's
doing absolutely nothing and now i think
uh richard yeah richard recognizes he
needs to get rid of some of these pieces
exactly and maybe
even trading a pair of knights after
you've played bishop b5 makes a lot of
sense
to my eyes only that the knight on b5
again was just not doing
didn't have a good enough roll how come
i can never get rid of my arrows there
you go thank you bishop b5 and king g8
after h5 yeah so
dude is saying that he is not really
content to wait aimlessly he does want
to give mate on the king's side perhaps
with the light on f7 it's not going to
be easy i guess the the winning plans
here for white if you really are looking
for ways to give mate would involve uh
taking on g6 and then playing rook h1
bishop h5 giving up that piece and then
going for
no loud attack but that even that
doesn't really create
uh
an immediate winning threat and yeah
very much like knight eight with the
bishop steel on b5 which makes it which
makes it quite difficult for white to
avoid sort of mass trades of light
pieces if you go knight day four we take
sacrifice we go b5 they're very very
happy okay i think i think we openly
although yeah maybe we can take on a5
maybe maybe there is still time enough
for us to
to do that but night day four i don't
think is happening i think
uh he will play something else well okay
if you're if you're okay i think we'll
just go to each one
is actually hanging you're right yeah
if we start getting worried about the b2
pawn and we play a move like b3 but why
do we play
though yeah exactly that's that's not
the way to do it yeah exactly
maybe
queen c2 okay i kind of like queen c2
but then black and replies
he's taken on a8 or yeah
luring the rook away from the b file
makes a ton of sense because in all of
these positions i think bishop takes c4
followed by b5 is
very
very uh topical especially when yeah and
not having the rook on b8 there is going
to be uh
easier for white to
uh to handle i'm warming up the black's
position yeah the last few moves has
really been beneficial for black we do
have queens e2 absolutely protecting
protecting the pawn on b2 on the board
yeah
and now i like what you're saying i mean
uh put the rook back on b eight yeah and
so it does feel like you might have an
angle for
bishop takes c4 and b5
yeah whoa whoa whoa we've got a rook on
f3 how did that happen
just well the brook went there sort of
over protecting the pawn on e3 i'm not
entirely sure what for
it's strange i'm going to
refresh my board
yeah it's a strange move too uh the
troops be a rook f3
i think he's yeah he's preparing for
bishop c4 and b5 he
he needs to be able to play b2b3 in the
end there i can explain this yeah bishop
c4 bishop c4 b5
we take on b6 rook takes on b6 and with
the rook on f3 we can actually play b3
here which is which is massively which
is massively important because it kind
of immediately ends all the count to
play on the b file and with the e3 pawn
protected thanks to the rook on f3 it
all makes sense okay
um
still a very awkward move and it might
encourage black to start to think about
people doesn't really create a threat
right true i probably play bishop too
and then i start slowly showing showing
all of this pushing me out
wins queen c7 quincy seven played
another kind of a waiting move okay i
think bishop f2 is logical now the
bishop g3 isn't really doing very much
and we want to if we have a rook on the
third there it's much rather yeah
exactly you you'd much rather have it on
h3 okay as a kind of a hint that maybe
eventually something good will happen
should be 3300 for now
we still have a similar very very good
day right not just yet i would guess but
maybe uh in some kind of a future you
you might want to queen e7 again richard
kind of like
he's reacting he's reacting but i do
want to say like i i very much like the
improvement uh richard has made his
position the you know trading one night
and and potentially trading the other
one on c4 as well but the knight on f7
is still completely completely hamstrung
by the structure and uh just refreshing
my board everybody don't get
where are you there it is
b2b3 okay
now this rook
somehow wants to make it to the king
side rook a2 and
okay you were saying this knight on f7
needs a better life yeah
i don't know
maybe you just give it up and he started
with the move bishop takes c4 and he's
going to come what do you take with
i
i take with the
queen
no
i didn't take with the queen
he took he did he just take with the
queen yeah and and now you do start to
push for e3 because e3 4 now is
borderline winning in terms of
g6 is so weak exactly and like ideally
you would like to go okay
but this this looks so strong that maybe
you can't even waste any time be
preparing it i i agree you would much
rather have your rook
yeah but black obviously plays b5 queen
takes b6 and there's going to be some
counter play on the queen side so uh
looked upon him yeah young shirt clearly
feels he doesn't have time to
i want to say white is playing a very
very nice controlled
game thus far i mean it's very hard to
play 23 23 played here this is a
horrible position for black
you you get kind of swept away on the
king side very very often in these types
of positions the rook can come in by a28
g2 or a4 e4 in some positions it's just
very very bad for black g6 i mean h6
played
and uh
yeah bishop h7 bishop g6 is one way to
deal with this you're obviously much
much better if you just play g5 g6 here
but i was about to say i go g6 i go f5
you're right you've got to blockade but
enjoy yourself
i mean
you'll be pressed against the hard wall
whichever whichever square you choose
for tonight it's not going to move from
there in the foreseeable future so
that's correct yeah i mean it's
yeah right but bishop h7 is playing for
the chess
is is is very attractive yeah this is
what my my eye was drawn to immediately
as well because you do want to end the
game quickly
and bishop takes h5 on white's agenda as
is just bringing once again the rook
over to the h file something like that
yeah bishop takes h5 he's playing very
very simple chess here just improving
yeah picked up the pawn on h5 hg
probably ends up self-mating
so yeah we heard just
desperately trying to bring some pieces
into the game because rugby e8
if the rook wasn't on a3 exactly yeah
like if that rook was in play the game
yeah the game would already be over so
which is why
uh
the young polish player is now
uh swinging it over to some more
relevant squares queenie seven seven
oh yeah queen e4 you have to play queen
e4 now but the issue hg played whoa and
fg knight takes g5 is the idea i guess
right e8 is hanging yeah yeah knight
takes g5 let's go this is maybe not that
clear anymore hold on as he made it
yeah well this is not completely alive
for black
well i suspect the bishops are strong
enough
i mean it's compensation but it's by no
means he's under the g6 pawn though yeah
he's back he's back to being probably
just objectively lost here he just i
think he just forgot the 6 was hanging
or something
wow
this is objectively back to being yeah
bishop b7 maybe you're not actually
losing anymore you put the knight on d6
and you blockade everything
even bishop v6 is playable but i would
prefer 96 just to make sure you don't
blunder something we should see what
okay sorry
yeah okay
i'm losing my mind there yeah i thought
the bishop went to f3 but they didn't
uh interestingly uh young
did not capture uh d6 it wasn't bishop
c7 was making a draw there yeah yeah
that is absolutely true yeah yeah this
is now going to be
i would assume yeah this
uh in the meantime vishy won wesley drew
against gabrielesko what
um
wesley drew oh my god i mean david is is
picking quite the moment to suddenly
play
uh like he belongs with this group trust
me did you play b6 on just play b6 and
make a draw here what are you doing
richie yeah he's making it hard on
himself isn't he isn't he yeah yeah
especially with the king cut off on f4
like right like at some point well i
mean
b6 the setup the setup is completely
solid though like bishop c596 setup
doesn't allow any kind of an entrance i
think he's playing he's playing for a
win after especially after bishop b4
that explains everything
now you take a pawn and there's a fork
on c5
don't want to allow knight c5 check
and i think it's going to be a draw
anyway
like now who's playing for him
and we shake hands okay very nice
wow
let's switch
that was the last game
and what happened in some of the other
games please alejandro because
this one was a very very very tense
fight levon aronia we haven't been
talking about him enough today because
guys i think he's four out of four yeah
yeah with three out of three three out
of three four out of four for levon
beats radek voy tashek in a great game
this is very complicated but radic in
the last
seconds of this game
loses control everything is hanging this
are two opposite-colored bishops but
both queens hunting down the opponent's
kings who's going to get there first
king e2 is very safe though the bishop
is controlling d3 no queen f3 on the
other hand queen f8 and queen d8 are
both big ideas here for the black white
side specifically queen d8 is very
strong the idea here for black and the
only move in the position is kind of
hard to find king g5 king f4
hide the king behind this bishop behind
this bishop and find some kind of uh
safety also the king is going to allow
queen f3 and actual mating threats
instead the move d3 check was a huge
blunder because after bishop takes d3
you're faced with the move g5 as well as
the moves queen f8 and queen d8 cleat h6
radek actually lost some time i believe
here but he's completely lost the move
g5 would have been a very nice way to
finish the game but other moves win as
well you can see that there's two extra
pawns here for the wide side lavon
erodian on a roll another person that's
kind of on a roll today
is fabi favi won again now with the
black pieces against anton korobov and
you can see the difficulties of white's
position already here after the move
knight c8 yes you have a nice blockade
on e4 yes you have a nice bishop on g2
but this king only one no safety
anywhere on the board can't even castle
legally because the rook is cutting him
from that side of the board even if you
could castle it's not entirely safe
sorry on the king side rook f1 queen e7
and after rook f2 queen h4 this pin is
unbreakable there's nothing you can
really do about it
black is going to chop this knight on e4
very soon and with that goes the defense
of the rook on f2 no way to improve your
position you're just kind of waiting for
black to execute his final mistake uh
his final blow and that is exactly what
happened here
uh
after bishop d5 as queen takes h3
started picking up every pawn and favi
eventually won with the extra position
the extra material and uh it is now
actually levon aronian that passes
richard rapport
into second place let's go to poland
with the rest of what happened in this
round
thank you alejandro well one game that i
want to focus my attention is the one
between gary lesko and wesley saw
because this was a war of attrition
let's see what happened gary lesko
started off with the sicilian that he
essayed in the first round against
aronian as well and let's see what
happened out of the opening once again
he managed to build up a nice advantage
critical moment at this point after h3
a4 a5 taking a lot of space on the queen
side now the whole idea of wise position
is at some point ago knight to d5
exchange something on a d5 and after
that you're going to be able to
overwhelm black's position on the queen
side with b4 followed by c4 just take
all the space on that queen side he
missed this moment he played the move
knight to d2 which allows black to get
this break with d5 critical break which
allows black to actually gain the
advantage so let's see what happened
rook to d8 followed by massive exchanges
on d5 rook to e1 knight to e6 and this
position already black has a very nice
advantage but unfortunately for wesley
he missed the critical moment the simple
rook f to d8 after knight to f1 take on
c1 exchange and right now i can just
simply take on a5 give me the pawn i'm
going to be a pawn up and you don't have
any compensation instead of that he
started off with knight to f4 which
allowed white back into the game queen
to c4 to c5 queen to f1 bishop to h6 and
now a nice find by white bishop takes f4
take on e4 take on h6 your structure on
the king side is completely damaged at
this point and he actually built up a
very nice winning devastating advantage
why that is gary lesko clear chance of
taking down wesley saw after taking down
vichyal nand in last game but
unfortunately for him all the way down
to this point
b5 he played the natural king to g5 rook
to a1 attacking the pawn on a2 would
have won on the spot he played king to
g5 and he was just one move short of
winning this one wesley saw saves the
game in this one anastasia
yeah such a nice game great for gabriel
lesko him he actually came back to the
tournament so
this one was really tense the game
between which shannon started slowly but
later on um kirill shevchenko managed to
to win a pawn
at a certain point yes let's let's go
he's somewhere he okay a little bit
earlier all the way up to c4 yes yes and
uh and then what happened is that um we
should found a way how to come back to
the game and created actually
quite good initiative and later on
manage even to win back those the pawn
and
what happened after all these exchanges
is that actually black is controlling
e-file everything seems fine while white
was trying to create some kind of attack
but it didn't work
it's not going anywhere you have to
defend against uh all sorts of knight to
f2 gaining a lot of material for black
yeah i wish it went the other way and i
want to come to this very nice critical
moment when vichy found such a nice
actually um
sacrifice let's go all the way here and
after history i don't christian it was
really nice i think he found calculated
everything until the end he just simply
took this bone on c3 and after uh queen
takes c3 there is no way to defend
against knight h3 checkmate yes so a4
the only move more or less and then
after this check we can see a nice
another nice fork queen takes d1 he
takes d1 and after 93 he won uh the
queen back and he ended up in the
winning night ending yes which he
converted very very nicely without any
chances for his opponent what a nice
victory of vishan and it's such an
important victory because uh he lost
against david gravrilla and immediately
bounced back the mark of a true leader
guys back to you in the studio in st
louis thank you both uh very exciting
and this is the end of that game that
you referenced wesley so uh
queen queen yeah and then give me
another queen and then mock wins yeah
give me another queen very nicely done
by the way wesley understanding how how
it's done you finish finish taking and
then without releasing the pawn you pick
up the queen and you replace it with a
queen check check yeah and uh suddenly
it's naked kings nobody nobody left
there nice finish nice finish peter i
mean come on four very very eventful
rounds
and the leaderboard is shaking
again yeah this vicious still continues
uh being in a very very safe spot there
on 16 and a half yeah look at the
chasing wolf one lavon iranian level
what a different story of the chasing
walls right level on four out of four
fabi there with 12 and a half yes
four and a half but he's three and a
half out of four and the others wesley
two and a half not bad but rich here and
duda where are they waiting fading and
for duda who did so well in the world
bliss championship this is a
disappointment to only have one point
out of four but it's crazy because we've
got five games remaining and the game
the round that's coming up round five is
going to feature yeah i say it yeah
number one versus numbers absolutely
yeah this is the one we want to watch uh
this year with the white pieces against
levon but there's plenty of other
exciting uh match-ups uh the old polish
dual there at the bottom with radik
playing white against duda wesley plays
shivchenko
fabi fabi's white against gabriele
has been playing david is coming back
yeah he's been playing really well he
could have been on plus one he you know
wow completely winning position against
wesley
and before the
event started we asked the players about
their expectations for this blitz and
we're going to see you on the other side
of their answers
[Music]
what are your goals and expectations
coming into this event
i don't know just like last year i'm
coming after a very long layoff and
i'm just happy to play i'll try to do my
best
i
don't have a sense of what my
expectations should be but
you know i've trained a little bit
hopefully it'll go well so i will just
have this feeling that
just to enjoy uh
playing here in my in my city and
playing against such a strong guys
yeah i mean i i need to do well um and
for the overall grand chess tour
standings
and of course ideally to win it would be
great and that would put me in a very
good position and also give me a
generally very good feeling you know
it's
it's a super strong event so it's not
like
uh winning it is easy at all it's super
tough but
um but i have my hopes that that this
will be my
uh my my shop
yeah i'm happy to perform very well play
my very best choice and just enjoy the
tournament
i don't put much pressure on myself
and just want to
you know feel
joy and excitement and
yeah and it's
always combined with a good result
so yeah like last time i said
that i was hoping to survive the event
and it's pretty much the same since
i made so many one more blunders just
within a week a week ago so i think you
know
if i avoid
doing
repeating the same mistakes
i will be happy man regardless of the
results
yeah sir i want to be able to
try to play some good chess like i mean
in romania i think i
played quite well
so i just want to continue that uh
you can't really predict who's gonna win
and all that but you just wanna play
well avoid making too many mistakes
the main goal is to eat all these
sandwiches
in the players room yeah and maybe
50 in rapid section would be a fantastic
result for me
but it was very difficult to predict
when it's about bliss i'm told for this
part of the tournament
uh it's awesome that i'm playing here
it's a great great event it's uh the
most important tour in the chess world
and uh hopefully i can live up to the
expert expectations and
i can play good chess and why not make a
few upsets
uh i
would rather try to win here
because
i think in romania
we had
this misbehaving frenchman so
he is not here so we have to take
advantage of that and try
wesley and i we have to try to take
advantage to get in the ahead in the
tournament list
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh welcome back to our coverage of day
one of the blitz in warsaw and these are
your standings after round four with
bishop playing against levon in round
five obviously ending obviously the game
to watch but yeah very very interesting
fight currently seemingly for second
yeah but too many games left to say that
with any kind of degree of certainty
gabby picking up three and a half points
out of his first four blitz games wesley
so started with a loss that is beginning
to heat up as well with two and a half
out of four again having lost his first
game we could say he has two and a half
out of three but lavonne is the man he's
hot yeah
he is absolutely on fire so far and yeah
this is this is the game we will be uh
clearly concentrating on
and for vichy uh
you think about some of the
points that maybe he's
left on the table he just had this
wobble against david who's our lowest
rated seat um
what's going through his mind peter at
this moment i think he's way too
experienced to let it affect him to be
honest i think we've seen him
emotionally affected by things that
happened over the board but
uh
it takes a lot more than just losing to
an unfortunate one unfortunate game with
white time world champion yeah
i think i think he'll be fine i mean he
he he has a very very comfortable
situation than the tournament he's and
he just won a game right he had he just
won a game
i mean these guys have played each other
tons of games in classical and rapid
but in blitz who do you like alejandro
that's a tough one i mean
[Applause]
has the higher blitz rate yeah he's the
higher lesser and he's on fire but the
american cup he picked up 35 points his
four out of four here right and this is
the key matchup between vishyanan and
levon aronian there you see their i
think i'm going to call it classical
rating
uh or is that don't think this is not
since they're blitz rating okay it's not
their updated blitz ratings but it is
their blitz ratings currently all right
these aren't updated but uh
from and we're underway yeah and uh
levon actually
what i really like about
dear god no
dear god not a brilliant yeah i mean i
wanted to say that something what were
you saying
of the top players
e5
let's uh
let's maybe so this is since it is just
a blitz one
levon is currently 28 27 and number
three in the world on blitz on blitz
according to the most updated radio live
writing exactly if he wins this game he
passes magnus
for number two for number two right
behind hikaru right behind hikaru yeah
oh
we should potentially be prepared for a
switch here because uh there are some
sharp sharp ways of playing this
position but this is not one of those
no i mean it still sort of depends on
what fish it does but if he wants to go
d4d5 or not but but in general this this
looks like it might be very very quiet
so we we should be so we're we're we're
prepared yeah but we're not we're not
abandoning ship just yet but we are
getting ready yeah
on
f4 yeah and uh left says no to yeah
once you see c3 here yeah we can move on
yeah i think i think we can
the voice of experience and where would
you like to move on to we have wesley so
yeah let's let's wesley is hot i i think
i think we go to the poll matchup which
which matchup voidtashek duda i know
yeah that that looks uh
from the openings that looks like the
most fun game yeah
h5 yeah h5 essay there by by anxious
yeah radical replies with h4 this is a
symmetric symmetrical ish uh c4 english
which has now but this point has become
less symmetrical
obviously deforested if all knight takes
d4 happened at some point
uh and these positions could become uh
you know they're deceptively deceptively
sharp in particular with h5 and h4
included
whenever white castles
i i have it in my my mind many times
eight eons ago
i have gone 94.
and the rook was defended by the night
not the intention
it wasn't just all bad
there was a pawn hanging i thought
um
i'm still kind of a little bit confused
about the move h5 and why was it
necessary for white to stop h4 i thought
the idea is to somehow you go bishop
here queen here
and knight e3
yeah but allowing h4 is kind of annoying
because then
i have been castled yet you know i know
how to kill me
i know but eventually you probably will
yeah i'm i'm not sure i agree with the
with this particular setup i don't know
why rook b1 is required either i mean he
wants to play bishop b2 but if you want
to prepare bishop b2 why did you need to
defend the bishop yeah the 65 wasn't
wasn't ready to be played i'm not sure i
understand why rugby one was necessary i
suspect he's he's uh winding up for e2
yeah
i mean still still your plan with knight
d3 this is sort of how you play this
positions but yeah you have to question
why rugby one was let's say more useful
than for instance queen queen z1 g2
which could have been played uh in
instead
and the reason why it hasn't castled yet
is that bishop h3 actually does simplify
black's task quite significantly i think
in the structure
getting getting the bishop g2 traded off
i think is whoa massively useful okay i
mean we've controlled d5 yeah i think
now we're blocking d5 we're taking we're
taking with the bishop and then the
knight obviously we're not blundering a
piece here with knight g5 see takes d5 i
also don't think we can tolerate the
knight on d5 very easily i don't think
black kind of dodges it with knight
eight or nine h7
so we take why pretty much never takes
with the pawn
yeah i think we take with the knight and
then uh the queen and he has not
captured he played 95 okay he played 95
he decides to
okay so that maybe indicates that he
wants to take on let's say against
castles he wants to take with the knight
and then play bishop h3 i guess what you
pointed out before i guess but once
again i can take with the knight here
and yeah
like for how long h3 how long can you
ignore this knight on d5 yeah uh as you
say you don't really want to live with
that knight on d5 it's reaching into
your position a lot of people also play
a6 and e5 brother currently has the
option of playing in in the position
they have on on the board right now
radik has the option of playing night of
four
which i would be interested in i think
had i seen it i would too i like that
move a lot in fact i think i like
opening up the bishop to begin with that
bishop has purpose
and i think it's a very useful move and
uh yeah um yeah he canceled in the end i
really like neither form better to be
honest than than than the castling yeah
even though it's you know as as the
quote goes uh gustling can never be a
bad move it can just be ill-timed yeah
that's it um and we do have uh
that intolerable knight 95 we always
recapture with the knight here cd5
bishop h3 would solve all of black's
problems for them radic stops at certain
moments and then i think ah what is he
looking at oh and you pointed out knight
f4 and i go yeah
what a great move and then he does the
the conventional
if you will uh
yeah i wonder i wonder why not
what's the reason to pause here maybe he
doesn't like bishop five i guess yeah
maybe that's the point
ninety-five bishops per five from black
oh my goodness he did take with the pawn
the one thing that you advised him i
thought this was this was not happening
yeah now off the bishop h3 i think black
is just completely fine absolutely uh
everything gets off-loaded the knight on
e5 has a very nice g4 square if we
forget by the way who's first on the c
final i mean our queen could be on d2
i'm picking i'm picking black here even
though it's it's very very level still i
mean you play quindito anyway you start
trading along the c file you're not
really wars
but i think sort of in in terms of where
this is trending yeah you definitely
pick uh you definitely pick uh
on the board in the meantime yeah and uh
yeah just to
we don't have to go there we don't have
to bring it up uh on on our screen in
any way but yeah the the end game in
iranian is
following following the uh you know
time-honored tradition of uh
simplifying and then making as
symmetrical upon structure as possible
and then trading the knights and then
which for fishy is fine yeah mission is
completely fine
and he'll keep that
a very solid draw against his closest
rival even if he has to pitch the white
pieces while doing it that's okay yeah
he's a very very practical chess player
and uh yeah he knows
uh that this is this is a
marathon not a sprint so yeah it's easy
to see uh white's
plan white's plan is as you say put the
rook on c1 on the chopping block trade
trade trade put the bishop on d4
uh
what's black's plan peter yeah i think
this is the issue black is very
comfortable i think you equalize
instantly if you play knight g4
but you don't really
like i think do the in particular in
terms of his tournament situation
equalizing instantly is maybe not very
high on his agenda right so he goes with
b6 queen b7 sort of somewhat improving
his queen position uh perhaps preparing
rook c5
uh
but yeah rather not interested radik
knows that his position is no longer
better so might as well just make sure
he's definitely not worse yeah would you
guys like voluntarily have given up a
weakness on c6 i understand it might not
be relevant at the end
i'm just always worried when i do things
yeah but i i think he's sort of
purposely
tempting white with something i think
this is part of why you play v6 there
you the temptation because i think you
know if i could resist everything except
temptation personally myself i would
have
i would have chopped the knight and as
you say
plant something on c6 whether it be a
queen or rook i don't know uh sorry to
interpret that peter but yeah
b6 came with a strategic risk
a bit i mean the the room getting there
is is not that important
and also the rooks probably will be off
the board in a second and the night
really doesn't get there from e3 okay
hold on hold on hold on so if he had
taken how are you going to take b
let's do it oh okay i mean but but then
in this particular edition i'm just not
worried about it landing on c6 at all
like f6 i mean
really yeah have your knight on six why
why should i be worried about queen b5
or whatever
that's a thor a6 yeah that's a god
yeah but in the wrong planet yeah
[Laughter]
i'm going to win that month i don't know
what planet you're on i'm gonna go i
would i could go queen c2 and queen c4
but i just wanted to emphasize yeah it's
a bit annoying but i think i hold this
but yeah there's no need to allow it
that's there's no need no but i like i
like i like the way that i like the way
rodnik is doing it he goes queen c1 and
he hasn't goes b4 and he has before and
he has a pretty clear intention i don't
know if he's going to get there bishop
takes 94 played by the way which
is an indication that maybe well we may
have blundered something actually with
white because
of takes d5 fins
i can't play queen c6 but it ruins my
structure is my structure yeah but queen
eight yeah but this perfect will be fine
so queen queen six black plays takes
only three and goes queen six yeah yeah
by the way a draw
was the outcome in the anon game
on mm-hmm
so what what are we but i think he's
blundered yeah this may have been a
mistake but we can take on g7 now and if
you take on e3 and d5 was check which i
assume you will
i want to play i want to play something
like i don't know which square to choose
i could probably play king g1 there
okay and then take all these seven so
basically seven ninety three queen e3
queen d5 check and then we're going to
play f3 i don't know i think i need to
king my choice is king g one okay king
g7 queen e7
and we're getting into those crazy queen
and poland games where this actually is
not a clean draw by anything because
yeah we just lack
good checks after queen sixth grade so
and richard actually has won his game
against uh on
g4 was actually
the choice
oh boy
uh duda really coming back in this game
we thought really check your check what
is this plan
oh he uh queen c8 at the end you know
quincy
and he picks up the pawn on g4 but he
picks up the pawn on he loses a2 anyway
and there's never any perpetually he's
i'm trying to go with the right i like
the other pawn yeah yeah
what okay dude
dude is
going to be
looking for and the most bishop f8 is
very ambitious but it's also it's also
strange looking move
i guess i guess he's very confident on
this bishop coming out yeah i think it's
fine i think uh
with e5 restricting the bishop on b2 as
well as well as it does i think uh not
playing queen endings is
by the way
there was a7 a5 there instead of he'll
play it now
okay sorry yeah for some reason yeah
before white gets in b5 himself right
right yeah
yeah raleigh is also in seven seconds
here so
you know this is not going to be fun for
him just play queen e4 here i guess or
queen of juan or something like that i
like queen f1 queen f1 just cozying up
to the white king that just
doesn't feel good for white yeah the the
only issue richard has here oh sorry
young christopher is the the bishop on
the f8 is a bit is a bit passive but
yeah queen bishop six is a good you know
what why are we not playing king h3
i'm not really at all sure whoa
[Laughter]
two seconds make a move why didn't we
take on f4 i'm curious
and look at him go he's going for h five
is very clever actually yeah because he
wants to give a check from eight and
then yeah uh uh yeah
and now f e i guess
whoa
we need two uh yeah
is strong 86 though
i
no no no
he could have taken the bishop no and
now
now he says it both of them see it oh
with the clock at the end alejandro the
both players had no time ah this clock
makes a fool of us all but let's take a
look at the other games we still have
stuff going on wesley is currently
playing
chef chenko he is winning he's
completely yeah and then end of game and
favi is also putting the finishing
touches against the other junior gallery
let's go and there we have
the handshake just we're just in time
for the handshakes everything that's
going for us yeah this is what we do we
live for that's a lot of poems but
for fabi
uh we talked about livonia yeah levon
with four out of four yeah gabby's four
and a half out of five yeah
is very much in the mix now and uh we
basically have a six horse race i've
been kind of keeping an eye on this
thing uh there are six players who are
very much in the running and uh for four
players who really aren't competing for
the sports by this point i mean things
could still change but this is a
situation right now and i mean vishy is
in a very comfortable situation well
we'll take a look at our current
standings very shortly but
but first of all alejandro uh with more
of this
amazing round five just what happened in
this game between fabi and gabrielesco
we had this position where
fabi with the white pieces got it just
an unpleasant advantage for black to
deal with because this pawn on d5 is
just permanently weak you don't have a
really good active plan you can't play
d4 and simplify this guy anytime soon
and after some shuffling
black was unable to defend the pawn and
specifically in this position after
queen c2 already defending the pawn on
d5 is very awkward you could do it with
rook a5 but you don't really want to be
playing that you're also worried that
knight c4 at some point will take on d8
for the moment the rook is officially
defended so it doesn't work but queen a6
was a mistake because after queen f5
queen b7 it seems like black is holding
on to most of his position but in came
the move
rook b1 and i think this was a very cold
shower here for gabrieleska because you
attacked the queen and black's pieces
start getting overloaded you're
defending d5 and f7 with the queen but
you can't hold on to f7 for much longer
check this out quesad7 rook c2 and now
you're running out of squares you put
the queen on e7 which is the only square
that can defend the pawn on f7 from then
you run into knight c6 attacking the
rook attacking the queen game over so he
played the move g6 and even though queen
f6 and queen takes c6 are both much
easier wins the move knight takes g6 is
also good enough eventually favi ended
up converting his extra pawn and extra
position so as you guys mentioned favi's
back in the mix there's a bunch of
people telling anand that hey they're
still in the fight for first place even
though vishy is
a head above everybody else let's go to
warsaw as they have the details on what
happened on the other games
thank you alejandro well another player
that actually broke the spell that is
richie rapport who won his game against
korobov and let's see exactly how he won
this important game bishop to b5 a
closed sicilian from a white take on c6
d3 very natural stuff up to this point
knight goes to g6 bishop to e7 and we
entered actually very quickly in an end
game which looked quite good for a black
fork or above that is but it does seem
like richie was more familiar with the
nuances of this end game a critical
moment came at this point after bishop
to e2 rook 21 bishop to f3 take on g3
long castle it still looks very good for
black you're getting the king to safety
closer to the weaknesses on the queen
side that pawn on a7 is going to be
defended with king to b7 also they were
coming to d8 taking the empty uh
square on d3 rook to c1 king to b7
this was the big problem for black
because after king to b7 he forgot that
he has the option of going king to f2
now i would assume he thought that king
to f1 was possible but king to f1 boom
knight takes f4 comes on the board and
after bishop to f4 rook to f3 and you're
going to lose two pawns instead of that
and by the way king to f2 doesn't look
like it's possible either because you
are allowing this check on h4 and you're
going to lose the recon e1 but at the
same time i can attack your rook on d3
if you take take and this is a winning
position for white he missed this
korobov that is allowed king to have to
allow the king to get to e2 and this is
what happened after this white is in
full control of this position you're
going to be able to maneuver your rooks
to create more weaknesses on the king's
side provoke black to create more
weaknesses in his structure and then
take advantage of this and this is
exactly what happened an easy win
by richie report and he's back in the
mix to win this event anastasia what
game did you have your eyes on yeah of
course uh
we were analyzing the ending of the game
between wesley saw and kiril shevchenko
but i wanted to show a couple of
critical moments in the opening uh um
maro's structure was played and uh this
move d5 actually
kirill choose to play this one was very
interesting idea trying actually to
break through in this center and even
though he gives up his pawn um i mean he
found really nice control play and with
knight to before he's bringing all his
pieces
into the game like rooks but then ruxiat
maybe was not the best choice um
perhaps he had some other ideas here
like h6 yes like continue with the same
plan you know trying to uh
take back this pawn on d5 bring his
pieces to the center but probably sticks
will be logical didn't didn't happen in
the game though and uh let's say after a
couple of moves like rook c8 still was
not uh so bad i mean because okay white
also probably didn't play so precisely i
think the the other critical moment came
here after a5 instead of a5 he would try
to play something like rook g7 maybe
trying to
get out of the pin yes get out from the
p and bring the pieces uh closer to the
center again try to get back the pawn on
d5 um
later on actually wesley just asked him
a question what's going on where is the
compensation for this pawn and actually
after a few moves it turned out that
black didn't find the best way uh to to
this queen is getting her rest all over
them all the pieces came back uh pawn on
d5 was still there position is not so
good and this is where i think um kirill
could realize that the the game was more
or less over he's still trying to stay
alive on d6
yes yes so you see this like this
exponent
just goes forward later and uh i mean
was he ever to get back was he able to
get back into the game at all not really
i don't think so i think wesley had full
control and actually it's not an easy
it's really not easy moment for kirill
who lost three games i think in a row
okay let's hope he'll get back to the
tournament still and this is also a big
moment for richie rapport taking
advantage of that easy draw between
anand and aronian and right now he's
back into the mix what will happen in
round number six well it's we're about
to find out back to you in the studio
guys only time will tell
and we're back a slow motion replay of
the finish between eradic and duda as
first he misses queen g for check first
time around and now he's got to drop his
king back to the first rank
[Music]
he could have played it in xd6 and i
have a feeling that would have given him
maybe potentially decent drawing chances
but once he plays bishop d4 instead of
he is
uh in a lot of trouble but yeah as i was
saying uh vichy is on 17 points which is
doing very well but there is now
a three-way tie for third let's take a
look at the current standings in fact
and again
the cross table being shaken up as the
americans are beginning
to show their blood skills peter
absolutely as you can see there are two
people on four and a half out of five so
far having a
very very nice day uh
wesley also doing quite well three and a
half out of five uh so far uh this shape
sort of coasting
hey guys don't mind me i think
it's pretty good it's really really good
it's obviously not like not a bad result
but by the standards of how how well he
was playing until then uh not the
greatest but he's literally increasing
all the time richard with that very
important win as christian was saying
it's kind of popped back into the mix
yeah and probably with four and a half
out of five is now only one one point
away from die for second so i'm really
surprised to see that duda who played so
well in the world blizz championship is
sinking here's our round six what's our
heroic game
we we clearly have a choice here there
are two very very obvious picks here
either levon versus uh youngster of duda
or vichy against wesley we've got to go
with that
vishy versus weston yeah let's leslie is
in second annan's at first come on yeah
that would be that would be the obvious
the other
games yeah but apart from that we have
uh anton corova on the white side
against radical goverescu playing
against rapport governors having a very
decent day so far right and uh kerosene
playing against fabiano caruana kind of
reprising their i'm not sure what their
head-to-head was but they basically had
this very exciting race in rigor after
the grand swiss which ended with kiril
shachenko winning the uh the lindor
asabi blitz with fabi coming second nice
uh so they have uh uh someone's
unsettled unfinished business
potentially there let me just ask
alejandra alejandro we just saw that
draw that vishy had with lavonne where
he
you know from his regal perch his mount
olympus he looks around and says okay
you're you're my closest rival i'll just
make a draw with you i'll make it simple
is he going to go for that strategy
again
against wesley
shut it down i don't think he
necessarily wants to shut it down but i
don't feel he needs to take any
particular risks at the moment he
doesn't feel the pressure he started the
day with a one-point lead right and yes
there are some people that are on fire
but there's not they're not the people
that ended up so closely behind him that
are on fire he's extended his lead two
and a half points if he keeps cruising
with draws with white i think he'll be
more than happy
especially against a player like wesley
who's so extremely dangerous one of the
players that's currently on his tail
i don't think that he's going for any
kind if he plays the berlin rookie one
is going to be played so fast
so fast four and a half out of five for
fabi and that pops him over the 2 800
mark on the library
that's an accomplishment right peter to
get in that 2800 class
it is it is always very nice yeah it's
somewhat easier in blitz i would say
that it isn't classical i do want to
know at what point do we do we finally
stop saying favi bada
i mean at some point
something just happened somebody has to
die yeah right right yeah 2800 what an
accomplishment for faviano
we have three 2800s in blitz and playing
under the american flag now that is just
insane
and
it's all important to our standings in
the grand chess tour as there was a
three-way tie from bucharest romania and
if wesley and lavonne
and fabi could do well
here
in warsaw
that's a big one
and richard also trying to get some
points richard started so well in the
rapid and now
he really did well he didn't start that
well but that second day where he won
all three of his games catapulted him
into a great position
just disaster today right finally won a
game right just finally on the
scoreboard right but starting with three
losses man that really put a damper on
his hopes he had
the best opportunity to come back and
put that pressure on vichy didn't really
happen
not not yet but it's it's a very long
tournament there's still four games
today and then there's a full round drop
in to be played tomorrow so
uh as long as he doesn't become you know
two downcast because he clearly is one
of the more you know openly emotional
players on the tour the players who are
perhaps the most affected by
not even the results necessarily i think
what upsets him the most is when he
doesn't play well exactly and he did not
play particularly well in the first
three games and he would have been uh
unhappy about that but uh he won a nice
game just now and uh
yeah for this tournament to uh to be as
interesting as
as possible we would like him to uh to
recover and start playing well again
fighting chess and what are they
fighting for uh peter uh
and here's the total prize fund for the
gct tour in general the classical events
get uh the 350 uh
prize burst and all the rapid blitz uh
events uh half that but still obviously
a very very good payday for uh five days
of work and if you get in the top three
at the end of the grand chess tour
that's a very nice hundred thousand
dollars to the winner as well as
bragging rights and title
and the money for this tournament i
meant though and for this tournament we
get uh 40 000 up top 30 25 rounding up
the uh the pedestal finish and 7 000 for
the bottom finish with 50 points at
stake
also as we've pointed out very important
for
in the eventual tour standings exactly
and again we're waiting for this around
six our
heroes game is going to be between vichy
and wesley so
lots of very nice
matchups but again we were hoping that
this key match-up between number one and
number two will produce the goods yeah
it it's it's clear the big but also what
alejandro said is the reason i somewhat
hesitated and perhaps was you know
somewhat angling for the uh
fully one's game against uh against
youngstown because there is a risk yes
that wesley that wesley you know offers
the berlin
and then we get the repeat of what we
just saw well we didn't see because we
switched away from it but
we could have seen in in the game
between uh
vishy and uh
left we've been talking peter about
great blitzers and you've been around
you've played all the great puss players
from magnus vlad and mary all of them
gary uh
some stories uh share
share
share where you've gone up and down
story is on demand yes
you know a fantastic way to make me shut
up
probably the only reliable way to make
me to make you got to play the trumps
when i got it so
who stands out for you have you played
with gary for example i i played
sports
less less blitz
i mean that's actually not truth now it
would have been true let's say three
years ago but uh because of the saint
louis tournaments i've done some
practice sessions with gary
yeah he still is unbelievably
unbelievably dangerous and uh yeah like
if uh if you're not on your a-game you
just get kind of wiped out and uh
yeah gary is gary's a force of nature uh
i did tell in one of the earlier shows
to tell the story of my first ever blitz
encounter with bishop we played some
friendly games in the in the chess-based
office i want to say 97-ish
and yeah that was kind of painful uh but
yeah all of them all of them are very
very good i it's uh it's hard to how
about the iceman talia anatoly karpov
he's
never i've never actually played any
kind of off the record blitz against we
never yeah my my dream
throughout my entire life was to play
billiards against him and that i think
materialized once but we played the
wrong kind of billiards and i got
slaughtered there as well
but uh blitz we never we never actually
played kind of off offline i i beat him
in a couple of tournaments i think we
played in an acp cup one year and
he was clearly i mean he still is very
decent but he is unbelievably slow by
this point
like he will have 10 seconds by move 15
in
in most games and then you know it's
yeah you still because of increment you
still really have to pay attention
because he will not blunder no but he he
does play slowly he is just not
mechanically as fast as as he used to be
uh so i think i'm i have a decent record
against names that aren't familiar to
everybody who
you found to be extraordinarily good at
blitz there are some you know local
heroes there that's what i mean i don't
know have you ever met chipotles
uh it's a smart chip yeah yeah i didn't
meet him in person like i thought maybe
at some point you could have you could
have
yeah but i mean he has he's become
somewhat famous because guinness also
wrote a very very touching touching
article about him but he was like the
the legend of the leningrad slash saint
petersburg blitzing he was a very very
colorful colorful character he published
you know books of poetry and uh
and also was kind of good at blitz
there are some people in moscow who are
who were also like arbakov who you
probably i have heard of it again
i think every every chess uh chess
country has those people who are sort of
so slightly under the radar but it's
unbelievably good and here we are just
like uh oh
okay
shows us
okay uh let's let's keep it alive and he
goes to the same knights e3 yeah he goes
back to the well yeah it goes back to
the world he won a very nice game
against in this line in round one that
would be encouraging of course yeah
how's vicky always white
right
against all of his rivals
wesley
it's a double round robin see you
tomorrow dude yeah she's gonna get a lot
of blacks tomorrow he was also white
against gabriel lesko
which he lost the spanish defense 97
that was not yeah that's just that's not
what uh queen
i think 27 bishop e3 97 is a very
typical move in all of these positions
of course perhaps indicates that the
bishops will stay on but no yeah he
takes only three anyway
um queen e7 knight f8 f6 knight
i'm i'm so used to the fight for the d4
square i think i think having taking
only three you you're not going 98 96
you're probably putting it on c5
and and then starting to push the queen
side like knight c5 a5 a4 b5 and so on
essentially as due to himself yeah
it's probably going to be quite similar
to what happened in the game now in that
game basically ivishi played queenie's
e1 h3
g and very early on g3 and i was
wondering uh
because
it seems a bit weird but i think we can
actually try to castle queenside here
with black i don't think you know the
the the one shield of the king exactly
the the the the feast the feast of pawns
we have in front of our king there i
think doesn't really allow white to open
the queen the the queen side very easily
the queen came to tickle g7 and
eight three a kind of indication yeah i
know you might castle queenside and i
might
pretend to
rip open
a5 is an indication that perhaps we're
not casting coincide because you're
keeping the apps you know yeah uh
keeping i mean with the pawn on a5 for
opening up the the queen side will
become a lot easier for white but the
thing is even if the a file becomes open
with the bishop on b7 and the king on b8
you're not really getting made to take
all that all that easily so
still can't really rule out wesley
gosling in the next couple
let me pause you right there peter and i
ask you the most alien question your
pick you're white or black
the fact that you're supposed to follow
this structure
i'm not sure i'm looking you know this
structure confuses me i
i think i don't know five years ago i
would have chosen white but
uh h5 was not on my
radar
h5 h5 and a5 um
it's 2022 right you know
knight kind of comes immediately back to
f3 and says wait a minute what do you
mean i think you play h5 yeah because i
wanted to play gv and now we go h4g
fortnite somewhere and uh
i think i i don't think we allow h5h4
yeah exactly i think we need h4 on the
board as you predicted
i don't know if this advance on the king
side uh yeah i don't i don't like aliens
what do you think what are you thinking
about i feel i feel it barely holds if
it holds for black right because you
never want to h takes
h takes f takes knight h4 because g4
knight h4 is big and on the board that
is going to be a huge night on f5 i
don't know if wesley has mistimed his
kingside play just by a tempo right it
seems that allowing this knight to f5
was completely necessary the same
position with last one of three is a
whole different story but it's just one
great piece
you've got to go i'll take my one
thing i mean okay but it's not like i
mean black still has his but
yeah but b4 i think comes very it
completely destroys any kind of
attacking prospects on the king side i
think this knife on the floor and i like
before it restricts the knight on d7
yeah
just just cutting it's not even that
we're hoping to give made we're we're
which we are always hoping
always hoping yeah we may not economy
yeah we are very much restricting all
kinds of count to play by having the
bishop with the pollen before because
c65 is now becoming much less attractive
meaning that the bishop on b7 is kind of
uh
purely purely defending the a file but
i'm thinking if this rook on d8 was
magically on h8 you started pushing
pushing yeah and i got some some
by any means and i think white's biggest
issue is this knight on scene look at
this look at this queen e1
inviting h4 let's go queen b1 queen h
queen a2 i think are you really
investing that kind of time to trade
queens yes what a party pooper
right
[Laughter]
you're right he is going for the queen
train but the end games are ugly the
other games are very ugly for you the
end games are going to be very very
unenjoyable so yeah i i like this i like
this you like trading queens oh my gosh
you guys are party poopers
okay um why is the end game so ugly i'll
have c6 c5 at the right the knight on
the 5 is just it trumps everything it's
wait a minute then i can
jump to h5 and g3 you guys are being way
too pessimistic for black's position
this is bad
i don't believe you
the question is how bad yeah the
question is just how bad this is no no
no it's not bad i agree no
no okay
come on
make a uh
make me a truth sayer
uh wesley
yeah i like this one of stopping king
ish looking h3 maybe on a good day rook
h8 and h3 peter i don't know it's a good
day think it's mainly a prophylactic
move it's mainly kind of stopping white
from achieving some of these
the improvements you you might want to
fishy is basically saying uh i'm just
going to play to
to stop
the issue still is how do we make
progress it's a very beautiful looking
position but we need to improve it
somehow eventually bishop c8 maybe he
seeks a bishop c takes a five in some
cases
uh
basically saying he's giving up whatever
checkmate illusions yeah with the
queen's coming off yeah you're not
really you're not really playing for
checkmate you're playing your structure
is much healthier the pawns on e5 and g5
could become weak at any point
uh
end games are just good for white here
but the question is exactly like how do
you how do you make progress from here
knight on g4 whoa there you go
blunder something if he wants to just go
knight of six i believe so yeah i think
he wanted to take with the rough note
uh he forgot about it about e3 e3
g4 look at this i've got a patent yeah
this is now
this is nicely
very nicely played by wesley yeah i i
want to say that this is not very very
unclear
yeah e4
you kind of needed to because e5e4 was
also kind of topical yeah rook d4 rugby
was not a big deal
rook d4 rook be way one and then it gets
it gets smoked out by 92 yeah uh anytime
i get to push your rook into a passive
position i always stopped to do
rook d4 rook b1 i think
i play king b7 i want to have the option
of playing rook 8 with k3 i played g4
and
you definitely want this this bit of
space okay so rook f2 king b7 who do you
like them black yeah by this point i
like the letter f6 is just completely
unassailable
meaning that white really has no way of
attacking anything at all here rookie
one is a good move yes
rook b1 rook a a8
still 92 right yeah but
aha do we play g3 at any point by the
way to yeah i think this one this is
what i was asking stopping king of
cooking e3 i think is very very
uh important or at least making it much
more difficult to do it slowly though
right okay one rook be one king
yeah
we have to we have to but i don't think
but i don't think we're enjoying it you
kind of crawl your way towards the e3
square e3 or f3 especially f3 now
they're the bonus on g from your lips to
vichy's ears both on about two minutes
uh so both playing quite quickly
considering it's 32 moves and it's been
a difficult uh
you mentioned the knight on f6 as being
unassailable any reasons that
knight f4 might attract you find that
square attractive i mean we're playing
knight
92 stops our team crawling out yes yeah
right
yeah so okay yeah we probably play
something like group b one here and then
knight h5 is very annoying
but i guess yeah i guess we just global
we go 92 and we grovel we actually go
like f1 e1 g2 e3 one of my king needs to
be there's actually no problems yeah
once the king reaches f3
oh yeah no then you're happy then you're
very happy one of my favorite words as
an annotator is grovel
and in this position white has to
gropple his way to a draw yeah uh i got
that from tony yeah i get a good graphic
i get everything we're saying black is
pretty active i like the pawns long term
well it depends on
maybe what about the timing it's all
about the timing knight g4 knight 93
perhaps i think this is why he's going
okay
he wants to scare yeah and vicious says
i am now less worried about my q inside
and i'm i need the king in the game so
he'll just go king of fun rook a3 i
guess knight d1 well if he if he can
hold on to his queen side with the king
he can also skate he's going knight e3
and then yeah rugby one and i don't
think he cares about this pawn
what what i don't think he cares about
sacrilege
that's fine the 93 king rook h1 i think
is just much more dangerous yeah i think
i think you're actually right yeah yeah
just go for this yeah like e3 i'm right
once in a while
yeah you're absolutely every broken
yeah because yeah black is very very far
away from creating any passers on the
queen side if the h4 pawn falls
to white white is suddenly
right back in complete control yeah c5
c4 is the only way to go but i think
he's actually
maybe lost now rook h1 c4 we take on h4
and we take with a pawn
and ruby to king of three we are
prepared to take on g3 with the king
there
it is funny that you are so sure of
taking with the king with the with the
pawn
i would be
i don't want to default check yes
he's given up the e4
he played dc which is also very strong
yeah yeah i like this too actually it's
very strong it takes advantage of the
fact that it works on b4 you call good
luck holding on to the bottom on the
file with the rook on b4 yeah the f pawn
kind of
you know is a semi queen but they're
trying to queen yeah
you have to play knight d6 right but is
that so bad i mean the knight covers the
f7 square and
even if i spend too tempting going like
king of three king takes g3 there is no
counterplay and i thought she protects
everything everything so nice no i mean
there is actually some counter play
because if we show this on the board 96
king king of three
yes uh rugby one king takes g3 can
actually use a mistake there but now
because
f1 no
rookie one yeah why is this a mistake
okay one rip takes e3 rookie one
oh
my word oh that would be painful
we have seen but we don't have to
blunder it obviously with the white
prince basically he has played knight f6
which is kind of curious to me because
why why am i provoking rook h6 i'm not
entirely sure or even king f3 then even
king of three but yeah
i liking f3 rook h6 then because you
don't have a good answer against you
know three right now i i agree with this
yeah protecting the e4 square setting up
flow this is just better this looks
borderline loss for black yeah yeah i
think he is lost
and then we can even take things
and bring the king back g4
yeah wow we have seen some massive
swings in this game
and rook h6 is definitely a beautiful
move
and by the way richie he heard one so
richie after one win
he's getting the wind in the sails as
he's got he got a second one guys that's
an important one against gabrielesku
rook and he resigned he just resigns
vishy on a roll
what a great result there winning with
white who said rookie one berlin showed
us yeah he just not me
let's go to the foggy game while we
still have it this is the game between
him and chevchenko
and let me count the material black is
up a pawn but it's not easy conversion
yeah everything is very very closed now
uh closed down so you you have to find a
way to yeah
okay one seems like a very logical
container i like h5 there's
fake threat yeah was a fake
check that's a mate thread but we should
be seven just covered
it's also good
those last few moves
were dominating continues continuing to
sergio and levon is better against duda
wow well it's better again
is it yeah interesting night ending
okay
he's better but as he is does he have
enough wait what happened well he's
gonna he's wrong so
he's being pushed towards the queen side
but the white king does not have the e6
square because or the e8 oh
he gave up b5 oh
no no no i would not i mean f3 is very
weak like you go like knight c2 and yeah
and he found 9192 which is a very clever
way of
doing things so yeah uh duda had to give
up on active counterplay but yeah maybe
this is enough maybe you just kind of
chill on those squares i don't think so
do you have to go all the way back all
the way back to g4 oh
yeah this is very clever this is a lot
of pawns you should not have allowed
that sacrifice was there a way not to
allow i don't think so actually
know that you saved that
just before b5 yeah he could have played
before i don't know why he didn't play
b5 yeah i mean he probably likes yeah
these are
generally winning i don't like king five
though what kind of move was that
that was crazy you gotta go king d4
makes a draw knight of two is just a
draw now yes
oh my god that was that was a yeah but
this is what i was saying that the
knight is a very tricky piece and you
don't always win these yeah this is just
nice night check very comfortable draw
there's just nothing doing
wow just take on e6 i mean you don't
have to but you could yeah
take an effort on f5 you don't like you
don't have to be you're good well i
think i think my the most shocking part
of it for me was that the end game was
always a draw
yeah i i had a feeling that maybe three
doesn't actually win against the knight
but
always always a draw
oh
did anybody tell you that nobody likes
what a party mover
even if he had played the right move
king d4 even in this position where you
guys were like why blunder the b-pawn
even this position so knight c2 is
correct king takes might as well because
if you play b5 i say three and not a3 i
just keep chasing your pawn and the
three versus knight is a draw after
knight takes before king e5 check
certainly i think king d4 offers better
chances right king d4 knight f4 e5 go
king e4 f4 f5 right you will have better
chances to win the end game more chances
for your opponent to blunder but after
king d6 f4
there's other moves but both knight f2
and knight c5 are the cleanest because
white zugzwang himself tommy knows about
this word zugzwang knight f2 you've
moved the king you lose the pawn you
lose the pawn you lose the other pawn
and that's all the legal moves that you
have in the position you don't have
anything else to consider
fascinating draw here between levon and
duda that has been a
topsy-turvy event but huge result there
let's go to warsaw as they have the
information on the other games that we
just got to see the handshake in those
but huge results there especially for a
certain favi who keeps putting winds
together
and let's go to poland
fabiano in advent is on a roll and
there's another player that is on a roll
right now that is richie report and as
an on you don't want to see richie
surging win after win and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now he's
playing gary lesko in this round and
gary lesko starts once again with this
bishop b5 sicilian and after take on d4
queen to d4 knight to f6 castle we see
ritchie report deviating from what has
happened in the previous games we've
seen e5 we've seen g6 well none of that
we're going to see e6 in this game quite
an interesting approach by ritchie
report allowing the marotzi structure
for white giving the advantage to white
but saying okay there's no way you can
kill me immediately i'm just going to
play slow and i'm going to try to
counter attack and this is exactly
what's happening bishop to b7 rook to d1
rook 38 is the typical hedgehog position
h3 rook to c8 queen to e3 this was a
critical moment after rook to e1 g6
gavrilesk with a golden opportunity to
take the bull by the horns after night
wave for and actually get an advantage
this is a double attack i'm attacking
both the pawn on b6 and the knight on f6
there's no way you can defend both what
probably black should have done after
this would be something like bishop to
g7 but after just simply taking on f6
exchanging this grabbing this pawn on b6
and unfortunately you're going to have
to suffer for the rest of the games he
did not see this move he played e5 this
is already a mistake and after that with
surgical precision richie rapport
managed to convert his advantage it's
all about the pawn on f6 and after that
that point is going to fall and let's
see what happened
exchanges plenty of exchanges two
bishops for black and the pawn on f6
falling as well as the a pawn rolling
down the board and this is exactly what
happened absolutely no chance for
cavalry lasko after he missed that
golden opportunity with knight to a4
anastasia what were you having your eyes
on i was held my eyes on on the game
between now
kiran
actually is doing really well in this
tournament so far only half a point he
missed right uh today and poor kiril of
course i mean couldn't manage today
again so it was actually
he thought for 20 seconds what to play
after knight f6 and then he choose to
play
not a good sign but after the game was
wish i can understand him so then it was
four nights
opening and um let's see what happened i
mean actually it was pretty equal
position until certain point um but five
managed to trick um the uh the ukrainian
player you see queen h4 since everything
seems logical maybe white could play g3
right away but he played queenie two
provoking actually for now checkmate
you have to take him defend just three
more more or less yes g3 the only move
and look how he played queen h3
knight rook takes c4 and then after
queen of three obvious move he found
this rook h4 what a nice beautiful move
you cannot of course take the rook it's
gonna be quinac to check the only move
going to two then he trade the queens
and after rook h5 it it turns out that
how to defend the cone on the f5 if you
play g4 you lose the pawn on h2 so
white has to kind of come out with
something probably f6 was the best
way here let's say at least to double
the pawns and that's the thing after f6
maybe i don't even have to take maybe i
can play g6 followed by rook to f5 and
then take on f6 so perhaps this is what
he was concerned about yeah so he
decided to play something different and
he he found this move f4 he came out
with this move probably hoping to trap
this rook but it's not that easy because
let's say g4 rook d5 c4 rook finds safe
place on d3 and that's fine for black so
he came out with the other option he
didn't play g4 but try to trap this rook
with rook the one first
um but of course after some sort of
counter chance
nothing could be done here i just want
to show that
this move a5 very nice move from fiber
just fixing bone structure bishop cannot
really go anywhere so he didn't really
give chances after that i mean the game
finished in favor of fabiano who is
really doing great in this tournament
surgical precision for fabiano as well
as for richie but one vichyanan is just
surging as well what a victory that was
guys what are we to expect in round
number seven
well thank you both anastasia and
christian because we have been seeing um
a great
show if you will
by vishy and non-peter very much so but
also the the the the the cross table
there you know it's a kind of a tale of
the haves and have-nots and that's right
they have outnumbered they have nots in
this tournament i don't know how they're
doing it but they're doing it very well
with five out of six but wow fat fabby
five and a half out of six and very
impressive we're gonna be back for round
seven we're gonna see you on the other
side of this short break
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys
that's our show now go start yourself
this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back everyone yeah
they're here are your standings after
round six with uh as you can see bobby
and levon is the story of the morning so
far all morning here not morning for
them right uh
on a combined score of 10 and a half out
of 12 which almost reminds me of what
was certain this one i found at night
yes you had something like 11 out of 12.
but fish is still very very comfortable
in the lead there's point half points
ahead of uh richard rapport who uh right
in the shape after he started with zero
out of three and is now on two and a
half out of three but since then
pairings for round seven is going to
tell us a lot about the leaders
as you look at the papi versus vichy
those top two matches favi versus vichy
but also wesley against auronyan this is
going to be a big one for the standings
yes and not to mention rapport with the
white pieces against chefchenko who's
had a bit of a tough day we know he's a
blitz specialist he has won tournaments
where these players were participating
on so it's not like he hasn't won major
events in the blitz sections but he
hasn't found himself today and duda is
looking at anton and he's saying sorry
my friend but i really have to win this
one theater probably yeah it's it's time
for for young sisters to start winning
games he's so far won one game today he
started on 12 points lost first two then
drew
uh a couple uh and then won one so yeah
where is anton conversely he really
hasn't found his form yeah he's had
moments but they've been too few and far
between we're gonna
uh for our heroes game we're good this
is the one focus on fabi versus vichy as
you said it best alejandro fabi is
having the tournament and so is vishy
yeah
yeah
yeah if if if i were to actually win
this one it really uh makes everything a
lot more exciting for well tomorrow
babies crack the 2800 club
in blitz yeah 2018 and 2010 on the live
list uh a win in this game will confirm
it beyond any doubts two huge pedro
specialists obviously both of them have
been playing this opening with both
colors for donkey's years and uh the
difference between has been playing it
since fire was born
yeah very curious what what five people
will come with here uh i'm expecting
queen b3 queen queen g7 and perhaps it's
time to actually play c4 c5
um we'll see yeah he has at least an
idea oh knight c3
this is the old main line the old
mainland this is the old main line uh
and uh it's it's a weird one because
generally speaking i don't you know i'm
not any kind of a trendsetter in
openings apart from the grimfield
but
a major novelty in this line i actually
got to i'm sure i wasn't the only one
who found it but i actually got to play
a very major novelty in this line a long
long time ago in my game against
vasilievanchuk but it's not going to be
debated here queen takes b7 here is a
topical move and we had some ideas there
bc b6 we're still following the game
between uh nepo and carlson from
uh the world championship match which
went queen b5 queen d7 a4 those end
games actually are quite sharp
but
the engines yeah the engines do hold
them and five is the first one to dv8
going queen b5 queen d7 rugby one
uh
and what's the idea here for example
this
fishy peter
well that is quite simple takes b5 and
rook d8
defending tactically uh doesn't work
because there's a mate on the back right
yeah 96 is the obvious is the obvious
response no don't don't don't and now we
go g3 we take the e5 me yeah
reestablishing the threat of queen takes
d5 um bishop takes h2 check would have
really hurt your feelings yeah i guess
we go bishop c7
looks interesting but knight h4 i think
is a very solid well that's definitely
six 25 quinces oh yeah you can take c6
and b6 yeah i mean b1 is hanging but we
can take all of the lights light pieces
bishop c7 seemingly played already
yeah there's no other good way of
defending the pawn on d5 exactly yeah
another big question oh yeah yeah how do
we how do we prove we're better here
with white i'm not really sure it would
be wonderful if i could get in two moves
in a row if i already had my bishop on
a3 i could play rook e7 taking advantage
of this pin yeah but obviously rookie
eight will be the reply and the the
thing about the structure is that
white basically enjoys the early running
we're attacking the pawn on d5 black has
to make some kind of a backward looking
moves but if you give black time to put
the rook on d8 and play knight a5 for
instance
you haven't equalized with white very
often there is because structurally
you're structurally you're not doing as
well and uh i'll say in particular in an
end game i would just add to everything
you just said peter and i agree
wholeheartedly with your words this dark
squared bishop well take a look at the
structure
it could end up being a passive piece so
you're absolutely right the early
initiative for white
but now you've got to do something very
concrete and that's what he's done he's
played c4 but i still don't really
understand why we're supposed to be
better here like rook no rook fda is an
attempt to blunder right because which
is exactly what i've done against vichy
in one game i still remember it was so
painful in the vsb uh i fell for this
whole tactic and i was like no i have
the
i have the square covered so i have to
do it with the other rook rook aj bishop
a3 is annoying me which is why
that was the reason why
this is why i played rook fd8 but yeah i
understand you
uh anything here peter
she takes
yeah
yeah this maybe this might be fine yeah
this might be fine um okay but it feels
like c4 has caused
a pause yeah this shitlist is thinking
now
uh the shitlist is thinking you can play
g64 nothing really has been you know
oh no no you can't you cannot do this
i keep on forgetting the queen is
protected i want to play g595 here
attacking the queen on b5 right i'm not
actually i'm not actually attacking and
it's true if you are attacking quickly
yeah but it's a trade
that's a minute 20 thing
the time control i would say allows one
maximum two
long things
and i think yeah you go rook fda the
point being after she takes d5 you of
course just play knight a5 you don't
yeah
queen there has you go you go knight day
five here or maybe even 97 if you are
feeling adventurous i am feeling
adventurous and i definitely would love
to park my night on d5 if that happens
white definitely has nothing
and i have not improved but
with the c4 break
bishop g5 is always met by f6 yeah you
can throw in bishop g5 it will always
provoke f6 but f6 really just restricts
the knight yeah it's just a useful move
black generally doesn't hate the idea of
playing f6 at all in these structures
yeah this is this is the issue with this
line of the petrov is that
you have a very very
narrow window of time where you can
create some threads right generally
speaking black's position is so healthy
that
in most cases black will be able to
parry them
and then you have nothing and honestly
sometimes you have to work then you have
less than that
sometimes you have to prove you have
nothing you know that's uh
yeah and and aren't already now it's
equal by the way fabi's turn to go into
the tank
i mean i'm sure he discounted rook fd8
because he understood that he could take
and now he realizes knight e7
uh causes a pause yeah can we just have
i mean okay i could put crazy moves like
d6 on the board but just bishop the x6 i
don't even have to calculate right i
mean queen xb5 is actually completely
fine because there can be one is hanging
but right even if it wasn't and i had to
play bishop take d6 first and now okay
yeah you can play 95 in some order yeah
yeah i'm trying to get your pieces in
discombobulate but i don't think i i'm
not like i'm yeah bishop g5 actually
chosen by 5b which is curious because it
has to be it has to be justified somehow
i guess he just will we'll just go back
to
g2
which is what he's done here and
try to keep the queens on currently the
problem for black is if you play gta e4
and q5 you lose the queen along not the
queen you lose some pieces along the c
file there's a lot of ruby one yeah
rugby one here kind of kind of ganged up
very painful
to avoid such a distressful
outcome yeah misha goes 97 yeah and once
again we're kind of running out of time
with white if blake gets to play you
take c4 and 95 you haven't equalized i i
got to get rid of that i don't want to
see that knight parked on d5 i'm
thinking he's going to play bishop b4
yeah to get rid of that bishop before
c5 he's gone
and this is the other way to equalize
but you also you've completely given up
any hopes of a shortage if you do this
just queen b5 and king of seven refresh
my board yeah like take stakes king of
seven is completely completely fine and
now we see why the move f6 can actually
turn out to be quite useful for the
second player king f7 is a wonderful
square defends a lot of business squares
the f6 pawn helps
tremendously let's just go we should go
knight c6 or kb8 i don't know you you
can choose it's
black's mission is just very very
healthy as long as we don't blend
ourselves nice might be a blunder though
i think c takes b6 might be a bit i was
going to take
now we understand why the bishop d2 was
chosen and vishy recognizing there are
some dangers hints
in the position that something might be
awry has played the move rook c yeah
we're still staying with this one i will
just say that in our second central game
of the round uh wesley has a
reasonably safe extra pawn against levon
but the one has some compensation has
good drawing chances by the way does
this set up for
six but c takes b6 probably yeah because
i'm trying to figure out if i can start
playing for a win here with black
precisely so i was thinking of trying to
take on on c5 in order to plan yeah
on c6 get my wonderful grunfeld
blockading knight on c6 and you wanted
to do it with a6
yeah and like the f5 approach yeah just
completely abandoning the idea of
pushing it on c6 i mean black will be
completely fine pretty much
regardless of what he does i'm i feel
but yeah i'm surprised the knight isn't
taped at the c6 square here right that
looked like very i am a little bit
surprised
but uh from from uh fabi's point of view
by the way what are the clock times one
against one thirteen
with vichy having the one thing yeah
vichy has slightly more good for you
vichy and now it's two
years and he's he's playing a la tempo i
think he just reached for his jeep on to
play g5 he's done it
he's
playing not just for space he wants he
wants to push this knight away from the
d4 square so that when he captures on c5
this knight is not going to land on d4
and
well fabi said okay
i feel you i'll go to d3
that strikes me as a good decision a
wise decision
that there could be um perhaps it's time
to actually take on c5
but yeah yeah but this is this is where
the knight always belonged i wonder why
it uh it went to f5 when they
own that excursion to f5 yeah i'm
thinking knight d3 knight before
and you're thinking knight c6 i assume
96 is
it continues being a bit awkward because
you kind of need to be
well king is six yeah he wants he wants
to perhaps maybe or walk it over to d7
in some positions not before played by
five now knight a6 is a bit of an
annoying threat feels like he vishy did
not play it in the most accurate way
possible with the xc5 knight a6 now for
instance is quite annoying for black
side especially because the the king is
suddenly city 8966 anyway you might have
to give up the ball on b6 now and fabi
are playing
his very illustrious opponent
through b7
[Music]
ooh
yeah wesley one drew in the meantime
rugby 7 looks very strong now and it's
probably not the only thing that looks
very good that looks amazing though
rugby seven yeah ruby 7 just looks very
very and he's done it oh my god i was i
was shocked by this move uh
yeah because now he realizes yeah it has
to go it has to go to d6 and b5 you're
still in trouble but it has to go to
d675 allowing knight takes e5 check and
rules seven was resignable yeah wait
what happens after dc and f4 that's what
we're about to find i think yeah i think
we'll we'll find out like there's some
knight of five jumps there the game is
sort of still alive but yeah this is
where you go fishy definitely on the
back
let me start pushing this is not that
bad this is definitely uh
tolerable to to a degree i'm yeah
stopping ruby six check obviously a very
useful thing for
uh for vichy yeah i'm not sure this is
so horrible rook a8 is now very much on
the menu a5 has a clever move there by
the way stopping okay oh they're not
stopping rookies
but yeah but we've given ourselves the
d5 square for the king it goes like c4
g3 and c6 though
c6
can't take on c6 those knight before
checking
knights yeah that is a good move yeah
can you you're still playing c4 but you
said there's a d7 check in the issue no
no no no
what is wrong with c7 nothing no it's
very strong the question is whether like
it wins on the spot or or are you going
to go through d7 first also that was
also clever
i really liked this well first 95 wow
stops stops c7 rig b5 does not win
what
what i'm going crazy that's what
the pawn does not take the rook the side
and he's got his pawn all the way
through
c7 okay g4 okay b8 i guess was the issue
of g8 right so yeah you you have to
assume this is now winning for
white for fabian because it's very
difficult to create con to play an
adventure i don't assume anything is
winning when they have one second left
in every move oh yeah that is that is
also also quite true i kind of stopped
working no flag
at some point somebody should actually
d5 was kind of made guys hello guys okay
then we'll find out
yeah
and they did okay but there was
meanwhile let's jump to the dude richard
rapport against chef chenko you can see
in the position that duda is actually
the one sorry rapport is the one trying
to survive he's down a pawn
yeah dude in the meantime won his games
against korvo huge result there yeah
dude it did win yes
sorry i had that game up on my board and
i thought it was live yeah live on drew
yeah so there's going to be a huge pile
up on 15 and a half yes
and
uh yeah it's up to richie right yeah
richard richie is trying to i don't know
if he's going to make it yeah this is a
very big this looks very long very bad
position rookie iii checking a five year
rubbish b1 that move rook d7 especially
his boss oh it was boss yes he's running
out of space for his pieces rook d1
and
whoa whoa yeah but bishop
and you have now you can actually you
can actually take now on h4 but he
didn't see it it's very difficult on on
this on this time obviously uh he could
have taken he can still take but i don't
think no he would not have survived the
people yeah the people needs to stay
the the f-pawn is less important but the
people enhancement it's interesting
he's playing it so well as richie with
almost no timer he's finding each time
oh
what a boss move
okay
[Music]
yeah this is very very nice yeah this is
very clever by curiel now it's a draw
somehow you just can't you can't trick
kinda kind of i think it's a kind of a
okay yeah just just take on a5 here wow
what a great end game
seriously that was it guys i mean every
round has been eventful but
some real real mixed uh
expectations i want to say yeah because
we thought richie was lost then we
thought oh my god he's winning yeah that
was a draw there was a lot of there was
a lot of swings there but i think it's
kind of a fair result when you huge
victory for fab but yeah
that victory puts puts uh
the tournament very much in flux because
i mean vicious still is cruising which
is still two points ahead of the field
but uh now the the entire field is a lot
closer to human fiber is in the tie for
third but right
and probably like 28 20 on the live list
well
not only did he crack 2800 he cracked 28
20. well he's the fourth rated chess
player in blitz i think with this
victory
yeah he passes artemyev and he passes
who's on fifth
mvl he passes mvl so it's it's right now
it's hikaru magnus aronian yeah and fabi
as the top four blitz players let's take
a look at what happened in this game
between duda and korabov because an
important one for the standings as well
duda in the chasing pack and at this
point korobov has done well to survive
to get to this position and if he takes
on c1 takes on c1 and goes with the move
queen g4 other moves are okay too you
can go knight at f8 materials equal
sorry black is upon up but the bishops
are so strong that it's actually black
that's playing for equality which he has
after the move queen g4 even knight fa
the engines think is okay it's tenable
instead he put the rook on a3 kept it
alive and it was white that was more
than happy to execute this lovely attack
on the f7 square not so easy to defend
you can trade queens with the move queen
f5 well after i take and go rook c7
again the pawn on f7 is just too weak
this rook is too strong on the open file
and instead after king h7 bishop takes
f7 we got to this position but it's
completely different than what we
analyzed this rook is coming in these
pawns are vulnerable the bishops
penetrated on f7 and the position simply
collapsed here by coral buff i'm not
gonna really go through the wesley soul
game against levon they drew it was
solid nothing much happened in this
position but there were definitely an
exciting couple of games as we saw the
end there of the richard game let's go
with our friends in warsaw to figure out
what happened in the last remaining
games
exciting it was alejandro that game
between richie rapport and chefchenko
was just simply wild let's see exactly
what happened uh rich europa repeated
this close sicilian with knight to c3 he
won one game with this one we he might
as well try to win a second one knight
to f3 but
a crazy moment came early in the opening
bishop to e2 knight to d4 bishop to d3
knight to c6 offering the repetition and
richie said no no no no repetition here
i'm not going to go bishop to e2 boom
knight to d5 out of nowhere not
attacking a single piece knight to d5
just take it take my piece if you take
of course after taking on d5 opening up
the e file knight to b4 could be met by
rook to e1 followed by d6 creating that
pin and it does seem like white is doing
quite well of course
he did not take on d5 when you see
richie report offering you a piece like
that you say no thank you very much i'm
not going to take that i don't want to
i don't want to die in just a few moves
bishop to g7 knight to e3 knight to e7
and it did seem that black was actually
building up his position quite nicely
shivchenko that is d4 take on d4
exchange castle bishop to b3 a
symmetrical pawn structure nevertheless
it does feel like black's pieces are
just more harmonious let's see queen to
d6 h3 bishop to f5 bishop to e4 and this
critical moment came later on in the
game knight to g3 rook to f2 knight to
b3 and at this point he took on b3 with
the pawn
critical was to take with the queen on
b3 because right now after knight takes
e4 you have the extra move knight takes
f7 and unfortunately after knight takes
f2 there's no queen on d1 to be attacked
so this doesn't work for black knight
xd6 would come on the board and this
would be the end of the game if you do
take on f7 then i just simply can take
take and the pawn on b7 hangs you're
going to lose instantaneously he missed
that he took on b3 with the a pawn
opening up the a file opening up the
rook i'm not 100 sure why he uh
recaptured with the a pawn and after
knight takes e4 actually it is chef
chenko who is in the lead right now
knight to f3 knight takes f2 potentially
an inaccuracy maybe h5 uh to redirect
this knight from the defense of the rook
on f2 so after knight takes f2 king
takes f2 your king is a bit exposed i'm
gaining a few more tempes as black big
big nuance right now but he did not play
this and after this it does seem like
black is still um having the reigns of
the position but after h6 knight to h6
king to have faith look what happened
here rook 34 knight to g5 everything
look at this it's nice
comes close to the case beautiful
pressure on this pawn on f7 rook to d4
queen to f7 f5 big moment i can
guarantee you that richie when he saw
this move f5 he started calculating
knight takes high five yes it's the
first
what i do think he did not see was that
after knight to f6 there's another
knight on the board that i can jump in
on h7 create this double attack this
fork on the king and the queen and this
would be game over after knight takes
five you can resign there's nothing to
play for because if you take i take back
not only that you're getting checkmated
in certain variations but you're also
losing the rook on c8 so for example
here boom i'm going to pick that one
that one up i have an extra piece
animating attack good luck defending
this one he did not play that bishop to
e3 which actually swings the advantage
in chefchenko's favor and then this is
where you guys got to the game in this
end game in which of course chefchenko
with the black pieces was completely
winning but he was unable to convert and
actually towards the end as you guys uh
saw he gave the advantage to richie and
potentially he could have ended up in a
losing situation and this is what
happened
of course
quite
quite a crazy eventful game this one but
anastasia you're having your eyes on
this game between voy tashek and gavri
lesku what happened in this one yeah i
mean they just uh it started all
peacefully more or less until the moment
where uh waitashik managed to
win the pawn
in this game i i don't know maybe before
was it a bit like an accurate move you
know helping him to activate his pieces
here and still i mean even after he
managed to gain this pawn things were
not going so great i mean black found a
way to
exchange basically everything and went
for the four rooks ending it appeared on
the board yes and uh actually it was not
so easy
to defend no no not easy to defend but
also not easy to win we know that all
these rook endings
they're not so simple at all and i don't
know maybe h5 is a like natural move
right in this type of positions yes uh
um for white and maybe black could have
stopped it earlier somewhere h5 was h5
so i mean it's hard to judge now but
okay i just want to show that they again
they exchange all the boats on the queen
side and
it seemed like three against two uh
again not so easy to win four wise but
four rooks endings continued and
i don't know somehow um radik managed to
trick his opponent and somewhere oh yeah
it's interesting it was interesting
black wanted just to exchange the last
pawn and basically you know it would be
easier to defend when you have when you
are on this side which is defending you
are really trying to exchange all the
pawns and this is what you tried to do
but but what a difficult move to defend
it was the only move it seems like rook
to way three would be difficult to find
of course counter-attack the pawn yes so
now you can go here i go to the e file
and wait what if i just simply throw in
this seven probably talking to d7 wow
what a setup what a setup so actually no
i think it was k8 wow and once you go
here i go rook to e7 now i cover with
the rook and then e3 is hanging yes
after this and this version is very
difficult most of g5 looked quite human
right i mean you are trying to get rid
of
this pawn but look what uh
radic found i mean he started to give
check and here was a mistake king f7 was
a mistake because he simply missed this
idea with the five and now actually
white has this uh connected pawns which
are moving forward and it it's not that
easy to defend this position
yes that's a good question actually
after this exchange again it seems to be
winning technically a winning position
for white and look what happened okay
let's go uh
and see what happened i mean the poet
was just simply moving forward and uh
exactly like f6 king of seven and here
it was difficult really to find what is
the best way um to proceed for white i
mean he played this king six uh
basically losing this
only four but i don't know really if you
can actually it was the end of the game
if you can find the the different plan
for white how to win this position
probably alexander was a computer
no
it does seem like what he had to do was
actually lose one time yes so that after
king to f8 i go rook to g7
now you don't have any way in which you
can remove the rook from g1 to attack a
pawn so you have to wait you go king to
e8 and after king to e6 the difference
is that i have checkmate coming on g8
you have to defend that you don't have
the extra tempo with rook to
one because rook to g8 wow we don't need
computer we have christians what a
detail that was
crazy round guys crazy round as we are
gearing up to start round number eight
it's heating up here in warsaw poland
back to you in insane thank you
anastasia thank you christian as we get
our standings peter after round seven uh
and as you can see vichy is still
leading comfortably leading with a
two-point margin
but he did lose but he did lose a game
to fabi which means that five is now
tied for third
uh tied for third behind uh richard on
uh 16 points and five
uh playing against uh rickard in the
next round and yeah fabi's tied with the
one and youngstow and wesley has
somewhat fallen behind
uh off the pace a bit with four out of
seven uh now that you mentioned it what
are our appearance uh
peter yeah and there are two very very
important games in this round uh
down at the bottom there bishop playing
against rihard rapper our number one
standing in the standings playing
against number two and uh the
all-american clash between uh wesley and
fabi uh only have a point of separating
them plus of course uh lev uh white
against anton korobuk who's having a
very lackluster tournament dude is very
interested in this potential point as
he's playing the lowest rated players
and now uh let's just go back to that
round because i've been tasered by this
game of richard richard just plays this
move knight d5
just as okay so let's play us i'm some
kind of a normal chevy engine
for me i gotta tell you i'm tasered by
this game this game was amazing to me he
just played knight d5 sacrificing a
piece for nothing
then later in the game he could play
knight takes f5 sacrificing the knight
for two pawns and
handmade
how does he miss that
things start happening when you have
five seconds i i don't i don't know how
low on time he was but like if he had
any time at all there it is maybe the
most mystifying uh
uh misplaced the misplay we've seen in
this tournament so far because yeah
your hand just kind of plays the move by
so you don't even have to switch the
brain off
you have knights on g5 it's it's it's
barely a sacrifice right to be yeah to
begin with because you sacrifice a piece
for two pawns and checks the king is
very weak on the faith the rook on c8 is
hanging which is also something you will
probably notice
it is just very very strange yeah if i
understand we probably don't have it
ready but if you could find find the
food
not playing that takes a five i would
like to know how much time he spent on
this move
and how much time how much time he had
while
while the position was on the board and
again we had a lot of difficulties here
choosing round eight i mean we we
thought we had two really wonderful
games but
i i got to pull us for vichy and one
against two has to be has to be the big
camera yeah
i know i know
the westlake versus fabi game is going
to be uh a barn burner but uh we'll be
keeping an eye on it but yeah we have a
back up and with richie
with black
uh now
uh
the vichy
you know he he is ambidextrous he can
play e4 or d4 but if he knows that
richie's going to be playing the king's
indian
yeah i wanted to say that levon actually
is trying to make himself over into one
e4 player right and he still played 1d4
against richard
uh because inviting the kings it seems
like the king's indian is what you are
getting these days when you play d4
against richie and right that seems like
you know a good deal so
yeah compare it again
against e4 uh compared to his repertoire
against uh against one e4 so we'll see
how
she feels about it we should generally i
mean of course he is entirely uh
entirely universal here he can play c4
if he wanted to he can of course play g4
but he's a 1-4 player at heart yes and
always has been since and i wanted to
make it's kind of irrelevant now but i
wanted to make a note that uh in the in
the rapid tournament
he faced the french a couple of times
and played the advanced range without
hesitation it's very very nice positions
very interesting games and then in the
blitz garlessko plays the fringe against
him he goes back to his knight c3 and
loses in 20 moves exactly
so confusing yeah i don't know he was
getting good positions after 35 as well
it's exactly the advanced venture
and it's
possible we'll see a french defense i
mean it's not that's why that's why i'm
bringing it up that's why i'm bringing
it up because richard has definitely
been playing the french uh in similar
spots where he okay quickly because it's
gonna happen really fast you want a
french defense or you wanted kings india
french um i would oh yeah i would go for
probably the french here so you're e4 we
got two i'd go for the kings kingzone
i want to fry the kings into you and
what will he do of course you were right
but none of us
you didn't get the french either wait
what's sicilian no enough of this bishop
moves i am so sick of people reaching
for the bishop against knight c6 against
d6
this is very this is a very modern way
of doing things i guess knight gf6
castles is going to yeah a6 i think
you go to d3 yeah you go to d3
and considering the fact that even that
gf6 provokes bishop d3 in some cases i
think a6 may be termed a slight
inaccuracy
um you get you get this kind of marriage
positions here bishop g7 you have time
to play with b3 i think really queen b6
93 i think holds things together
reasonably well if you if black wants to
go properly upon grabbing with like
quick queen before check and something i
don't think we're heartbroken oh i mean
richie just does it yeah like knight of
five queen b2 knight g7 queen
this suppose the question right yeah but
you go knight b3 you don't go knight of
five you go knight b3 knight c3 here
uh the bigger question will be let's say
if black plays queen c7 here which is a
normal looking move do you play knight
c3 and give rich an opportunity to play
bishop takes c3 check or do you play
queen d2 first no you you play knight c3
you play knight c3 i think yeah because
2295 is actually maybe a little bit
awkward your structure starts creaking
i'm trying to i'm i'm thinking about
knight c5
95 would go knight c3 right well then we
can get rid of the bishop
seven yeah i i think you play knight c3
you and also i think you take yeah i
think having played the opening you've
got to justify yeah queen moves having
played the opening the way richie played
it you just snapped take on c3 because
if you if you play knight gf6 instead
you have a very very poor hedgehog
definitely
so yeah
and this is now a mess because
structurally black is doing quite well
but you're missing some square bishops
yeah you're you're somewhat behind in
development and yeah there is this
structure
and you're missing a dark square fish
yes
the king is not even on g8 so you could
you could definitely keep it in the
center for quite some time b6 is quite
logical what white would like to do here
is to somehow teleport the knight from
b3 to e3 but it takes three moves
that's a yeah yeah it takes three moves
and this is the way this is the way you
kind of gentrify your position here with
white if you get the knight to e3 it
supports the opponent opponent's e4
quite well
eventually this knight will be on d5
asking black the question of whether you
want to take and improve the white
structure or tolerate it for it and how
how long i want to get rid of my
weakness upon a2 to my mind is a
weakness i'd like to push it to a5
richie stopped him
and you know you mentioned knight e3
this is this is
another way to another way to do the
similar thing we can play bishop a6 here
and uh give me a knife i might actually
take
uh because after she takes v5 maybe i
can take on c3 but i don't think white
isn't happy about this either because we
get full control over the c file and
very nice bishops against knights
totally agreed and by the way he didn't
really feel like he wanted to give up
the light bishop richie instead he
played oh yeah 95 95 queen c6 bishop p2
is on the board
oh yeah it's a messy position normally
you want to play b6 and continue piling
up pressure against the white structure
but white always has has some counter
play bishop d4 comes to mind you can at
some point throw in rook b1 even though
i don't think it actually creates a
threat which b6 also allows knight d4 i
don't know if it's a good move but it's
definitely a move
and then a moment ago
you didn't want to give up the bishop uh
for the night
uh but in this case he does have a very
very clever queen c5 this is why he was
pausing and this is why he went for this
line because it stops knight takes e6 uh
very very efficiently
you can go light at five though we will
say to you suijan zoo peter you can go
knight at five you can actually trade it
by a g7 though
no way really yeah knight of five knight
and f5 wherever the queen goes we go
knight g7 check and we take on e6 yeah i
think well that's uh i think that's a
heck of a way of fishing for the two
bishops i mean yeah all of this on the
board
but richie which i think is a quite
happy development but he gets to take
only six with the queen and not the
f-pawn i think fb6 would have weakened
his structure quite a lot but i think
he's
happy he's dropping the pc x pawn here
for the c4 yeah has a very nice position
but i mean
the fact that the pawn is on f7 is an
improvement this is all i'm claiming i'm
not claiming black is doing well i'm
just claiming
this is better than it could have been
if you were forced to take with the f
pawn
good point yeah now we go like rugby one
b5 right and we try to combine some
threats to the black a5 pawn with
potentially ideas of four or five or
four e5 in the center if that happens
you know i always like it when they go
h4 h5 matching each other you go rook b5
i go rook h55 yeah h5 queen b3 yeah 5 is
a great movie this
clearly is better here but yeah black is
not defenseless
black has no defense no i don't know
those two bishops that bishop on d4
looks awesome the bishop on e2 i just
don't want to uh blunder some you know
fork on the yeah i guess we take on b5
uh unhappily
i hope you take with the pawn it's kind
of a strange thing to hope for because
the position is bad but
that's hope you take with the pawn and
then try to establish some kind of
blockade with knight g7 and knight cb6
gotcha but it's not fun yeah and none of
this is fun your mb5 also very strong
yeah h3 h3 just to tickle a little bit
on the king's side kind of asking the
question whether you want to play g3 you
probably do want to play g3 he's played
g4 or which is also a thing that people
do quite a bit these days yeah realizing
that
it's it's reasonably easy to control the
kings well 20 moves from now king f2
king g3 king takes h3 it's very useful
so he wants to accelerate his
opportunity of winning the h pawn what
do you think about the maples aleandra i
think that this is a very concrete
position for richard to defend in
because if you take on b5 take on b5 b6
b7 might already be a winning no but 97
stops he wants to go knight d but that's
what i'm saying he needs to make sure
that 97 ib6 works and that's why he's
taking his time
rook anywhere on the edge file i think
is hopeless yeah that's terrible that's
terrible yeah those are really so you
take but you take your time making sure
that 97 holds on he has taken and played
97 yeah i think the biggest issue is we
can play rookie one now well
you cannot play b6 at the desirable bb6
because knight on c4 takes b that's six
that was why what i was playing for yeah
exactly but okay one yeah rookie one is
what vishy plays instantly and it's just
a very very annoying move because if you
play you can still play knight gb6 i was
looking at this you can play knight db6
here
uh and uh in this position c3
maybe you hold this end game
but obviously
you're not obliged to
uh go through this with white white can
uh quite easily wait uh before taking on
b6 right there wait a while like king
after kg3
the training
yeah
as black i would like to play queen d7
and follow it up with the 75 to uh
queen d7 and follow it up with e5 start
challenging challenging the he's gone g5
this movie now that move was not on our
radar i don't i don't like this uh it
might work tactically but if it does
like it it ruins your it ruins your
position it has to work tactically
yeah you have to take the pawn because
rook c4 k5 creates a mating threat
basically in the background again do you
want i think right
he wants he wants the
he wants the knight jumps basically the
position is busted strategically he
wants knight e5 with ideas of maybe
sacrificing it for the white king side
or put plonking it on g3 and doing
something with it after that yeah
there's queen and queen d1 that's the
one i was worried about because rook
takes a5s on top to begin with to begin
with and what is the move here
he's played something
yeah okay yeah if you have to start
yeah but that's what i was thinking
right not just a five but queen f1 queen
h3 queen eight shade is a bit of a
threat yeah queen f1 is a very very nice
move to make here because yeah it
combines
safeguarding your on king by removing
the pawn from h3
with uh creating actual threats that
black will need to address and the
sacred concept of winning a pawn yes
a trifold
rifle
yeah
yeah
richie played
he's gonna have to do that one day that
bishop on d4 was dominating g7 and
he does have an outside pastor now and
he also you know it will sound kind of
flippant but he has a knight against
bishop in a blitz game
which is
you know with the queen's still on the
board like if this is an end game you're
cheaper potential yeah but cheaper
potential should not be discounted here
yeah it's so
but i saw this queen coming to c7 which
in fact vishy has settled
upon and
and he just snapped takes on it do you
take with the queen
you kind of have to because otherwise
yeah otherwise just too sad because b66
67 seems to be winning the game yeah but
like this end game has to be has to be
lost after takes takes on rook a4 that's
actually wonderful because you're losing
the whole
but we can't really take on c4 that
comfortably right because the a point
starts running uh you'll take one day
well you played rook a4 oh we can take
actually but yeah this is a4b6 rook c6
and uh
and so now he but he's not in time to
play h4 yeah it's gonna be an issue yeah
rook h8 so we've we've reached this kind
of an equilibrium where white currently
isn't making much progress but why does
a bunch of pawns up
so yeah the question is how do you win
because if the rook leaves the a file
black immediately plays king c5 or even
a 5a4 maybe in some positions and starts
pushing
and the structure on the kingside is
completely rigid you can't as long as
the rook stays on the h file you can't
really touch anything there at all
so weirdly you know this is like a three
pawn up end game or something at two not
three but but it doesn't feel like it
doesn't yeah and fabi continues fabby
continues we say winning streak
what a monster what's going on
fabi's not good at blitz or that's what
i keep hearing people keep telling me
this
yeah i think what
d6 what a move yeah oh my word
because rook d8 was on on uh vichy's
agenda and rook d8 rook a8 would have
maybe
no we don't go yeah i'm not sure why we
yeah how do we win this
it's so annoying it's funny it's
incredibly annoying it's it's it's weird
how difficult this is and uh vishy has a
ton of time as well like he's
okay he's in full control on the clock
but the question still remains how do we
how do we actually win this
yeah the engine says plus five as i can
see on my screen now an engine is uh
unimpressed by the drawing potential of
this end game but in human terms as you
can see on your screen like vishy has
played so many games in his life
this is not this is not as
straightforward as as you would rook g1
is an indication that you know it's h4
and rook takes h4 what are we doing
we're going back to d1 and down to d8 i
imagine what king
c5
or okay yeah i'm not sure what yeah i'm
not i don't know
i really don't think this was the way
you're not impressed no i'm i'm really
really not sure yeah i mean he's gone
okay one now which is why did you give
up the h pawn oh my god it's the same
position but now h4 is no longer a
threat like now white's king is going to
come all the way back to a4 that's what
maybe he should have been doing i would
go rook g83 or something
that's what he should have been i think
black is just fine rook d3 rook c3 like
we're not worse even we may be a bit
better like not better i guess with rook
on a4 nothing moves but
hang on rook b4 is a threat in some
positions
in the square
he's just making a very comfortable draw
now without the h-bone just very very
comfortable wow not a single issue
that is just yeah and this is what i was
talking about here this is not a plus
five that you know you associated five
yeah i think we have one game remaining
and that is between carroll
and radic yep the drawn bishop ending
and they've also live also winning uh
winning
and dude also one yeah yeah everybody
that everybody right here at the top
so there's basically now four people
behind this show and 16 16 and a half
with with visual and 18 and a half yep
i've been keeping track yeah rudder is
better but not winning i would suspect
right you just play for
the bishop on g5 it's pretty dead yeah
this is just very very equal
yeah as long as you play a4 if it gets
stuck on a2 then maybe you get some
problems but as long as you don't forget
to play a4 there's just nothing here you
just shuffle forever when we share with
squares you like
yeah yeah
you have to be prepared to meet g4 check
with king takes g4 and king e3 you you
kind of would like to be playing e4 e5
there with the bishop analog diagonal
but i should get a f5 g4 is a thread
question mark
you have to you have to do it yeah it's
the only way to even create a question
then the problem is the bishop goes back
to the king will go to f5 the bishop
will go back to c4 yeah it'll cover the
f1 square yeah you might you might be
playing for a lost thing that was about
to say it could be a suicide march if
you if you over press there you might
actually be playing for a loss
yeah i think the biggest risk here
really is that somebody forgets that
they're on five seconds and things for
too long
i think this risk is over yeah and
that's it it's a draw
between chefchenko and avoid tasha let's
take a look at what happened here in the
wesley game because that was such a huge
one for the standings things got kind of
crazy it was a petrov you can kind of
recognize the structures here and
wesley castle in queenside favorite
castle in kingside and both sides
attacking but it's clear that in this
position it's black that has the better
attacking potential wesley hasn't been
able to open anything on the king side
all three pawns still alive all three
pawns alive but this structure means
that there's a half open b file that
favi can work on and things compound you
go rookie b8 you need to defend the
spawn you could go queen a3 but queen b4
is an issue b3 allows a4 b3 gives me a
hook to attack the queen side with by
the march of the a pawn down the board
so b3 a4 and wesley is already in
trouble now this wasn't the losing uh
mistake we had a couple of issues here
after rook a7 and perhaps king b2 even
though the engines don't agree exactly
with what favi did i think was the
losing idea because in this position
after queen c8 rook b5 rook a2 check
wesley
must have thought that something was
wrong with the move king c1 the engines
don't see what it was instead he
catapulted his king all the way to c3
and even though there were some more
adventures in the game the king is just
too weak i mean you're not going to
survive with the king on c3 bishop d7
rook b4
even though this is technically a
mistake after queen e7 and c5 because
rook b6 somehow the computer says holes
for white whatever he played instead of
rook f4 which is a much more human move
attacking the pattern f7 but after
bishop e6 it's the king that gets caught
i mean you don't have any queen threats
nothing
nothing the king is just isolated from
the rest of the pieces and after king d2
which was not the best move but it was
hard to suggest something by this point
queen b8 was a lovely finish this rook
surprisingly in a bad position can't
hold on to its position on the fourth
rank and if you go to f3 then the queen
comes down to b4 check again not a good
way to defend from the check go down to
the first rank rook a1 is an issue c3
rook a2 is an issue rook c3 d4 is an
issue and on king e3 which was played
queen uh to defend the rook queen e5
czech or immediately wins the game the
king cannot keep defending the rook
because the move played in the game king
f3 fails two bishop takes g4 check and
wesley resigned in this position as his
queen on e7 is hanging so an important
result there for favi crushing the day i
believe he's on seven and a half out of
eight
hello and i believe he just knocked
magnus down to number four in the world
as he's catapulted himself to the top
three
world beatles lev is number two five is
number number number three uh what
baby has gained 90 rating points let's
jump over to warsaw
90.
well
fabiano is surging but another player
that is surging is levon aronian and he
was playing against a player that is
just simply struggling today anton
korobov only on one point out of eight
games two draws and lost every single
other game let's see what happened in
this one levon started with e4 c5 knight
to f3 d6 and c3 gunning for a very slow
game knight to f6 bishop to e2 of course
you cannot take on e4 because queen to
a4 is coming and then we got all the way
to this position we see this very slow
game building up after bishop to f1
korobov decided to start his attack with
g5 this is an inaccuracy it's the wrong
way nevertheless the natural way to
respond what he was supposed to be
focusing on was actually f7 f5 so you
start off with knight to a e6 you're not
allowing white to take on f4 and after
that you're going to build up your
attack after f5 king to h7 f4 a king's
indian type of attack
he did not do that he played the move g5
and after b4 b6 b5 now white is just
simply taking over and i have to say i
was
browsing through the game and lev
aronian did not release the advantage
one single moment and we got all the way
to this position
b takes a5 another critical mistake
allowing the rook to invade via the a
file and now the a7 pawn is hanging you
will lose that and i will have the b
pawn getting ready to promote and this
is exactly what happened pawn goes all
the way to b7 you are not checkmating me
on the king side and this is all she
wrote anastasia what happened in the
game between gary lesko and duda because
this one was a wild one as well yes it
was a wild one in incentive actually
young kristoff decided to play very
risky right out of the openings he chose
this variation with knight f6 and
actually uh david got really good
position after the opening and um just
look
here for example i mean
it's clear that this d7 pawn where it
goes i mean where black will be castling
i mean there are many questions black
has to answer
and rook h3 an interesting move to bring
the rook on the third rank and i want to
to go to this moment uh still i mean
even the computer hates position of
black it's not that easy to still uh
understand everything here playing with
white because king is still under
sometimes under some attack so
he was trying to do to do something to
make position more sharp c4 you know
trying to open the bishop maybe king
seven later once again the problem that
you were mentioning at the uh at the
beginning the pawn on d7 yes he's trying
to cover it as well with the bishop on
d5 and after 94 he went for this bishop
g to move pro walking actually uh david
to go for this crazy line starting with
96 which turned out
of course but it turned out to be a
mistake rook you see was better here you
know just keep the position uh the way
it was so 96 let's see what happened
after all these exchanges you
can count the pieces now and where you
can realize it's two minor pieces in the
rook against the queen and um after that
actually now young it still feels like
white has some potential nevertheless
black skin despite the fact that being
open it has the two bishops around it
defending it on both the light squares
and the dark squares that's true and
actually young sister who played very
very precisely after that moment and
didn't give really chances to his
opponent even though of course david was
trying to create some kind of attack so
great victory for young sister who is
trying to come back to the tournament
huge victory that was as we are gearing
up for the final round we will go to a
commercial break stay with us we'll be
back shortly
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a good day today
welcome back with the final round of the
day today uh and these are the standings
for you and uh some some
seismic shifts there certainly uh with
with wesley being you know the clear
loser of the leading group there 42
rating points he's dropped right that's
probably also probably also includes the
uh the american cup though uh i have a
feeling so yeah she didn't have a
stellar american cup
but uh fabi yeah peter seven and a half
out of eight that's phenomenal bobby is
crushing today
is a monster and honestly like six and a
half that levon has scored would have
been a headline story of course but it
isn't because we have fun look at these
pairings for our our ninth and final
round though peter look at that yeah and
they are playing each other so uh it's
gotta be our heroes game if you will
yeah it has to be has to be the the game
within 5b and lebon up top there but
there's a four-way tie for second as you
can see with the richard and also young
christopher all of them on 16 and a half
and uh this is still
reasonably safe on uh 18 and a half
uh yes he will definitely go uh to the
clubhouse with a clear first as he does
have two points a lead
um
marvelous i mean it's just it's just
it's great calling interaction with you
guys it says blitz is very enjoyable i i
really like
i still enjoy playing it and it's also
very very uh
fun to to to cast it because uh things
are constantly happening and you know we
get to shout oh make a move make a move
three two one oh no
yeah the old nose are i'm still tasered
by how richard did not play knight takes
f5 and
i don't know if we if we maybe have
footage at this point wow that was just
so crazy crazy crazy um you know i mean
as we approach this ninth and final
round i just want to take a look once
again in our predictions
because guys i was predicting wesley so
and i thought wesley was going to he
started reasonably i think two and a
half out of four he dropped but whoever
picked fabi is doing i'm unbelievable
i'm doing i'm doing well for a change
yeah
you're doing more work
you're doing well for a change wow and
duda
lavon
everybody's doing well everybody's doing
okay yeah except
for var
bar how could you no oh it's terrible
yeah there's still ten rounds to go one
today and nine tomorrow exactly tomorrow
is wednesday counting wesley out is a
very dangerous game exactly and as you
can see this is the rest of the schedule
we'll have uh
uh the exact same game as the same day
as tomorrow as today with colors
reversed all of these players will play
uh each other again and uh we will have
playoffs if players aren't needed and we
should inform our audience because i
totally know this do we start one hour
earlier tomorrow
night
we do not that's a trick question guys
we do not have
i'm so happy that
we don't have to start an hour early i
mean
normally they do that because of the
playoffs the playoffs and
i want to say if this guy's if these
guys continue in the same fashion they
might one of them overtakes hikaru
tomorrow
yeah if they keep if they keep pace with
with what they've been doing so far in
this tournament you know one of them is
the new world blitz number one
that'd be crazy yeah that would be quite
something yeah if they if they knock
both magnus and hikar off of their
purchases
it's uh
it's quite you snooze you lose right uh
alejandro it's been a while since they
played blitz yeah yeah yeah
this is not supposed to be anything at
all i'm very surprised by what phobia by
what fiber is doing specifically the g3
line is yeah another thing connecting
with distribution i tried making this
work at one point and couldn't really
get absolutely anywhere at all it's as
white as white
thank you i wasn't quite sure yeah i
don't i don't play this with black but i
i did try to make this into part of my
repertoire with the white pieces and
like failed utterly
but
fabi clearly does this with with an idea
in mind because this is about as topical
as as it gets in the mechanism
and uh
yeah you you don't expect him to not
have and especially anything at all you
you've got these double backlines on c4
and c3 and you want something for you
you you want the two bishops you you
want that that this bishop on d6 has
traded itself overnight and without that
compensation of
something
uh i don't i don't understand what white
has here yeah what has some sort of
temporary activity and like already here
if you if we go to one move back uh uh
left spend the tempo on rook d8 there
instead of let's say knight g7
uh and 97 gets met by knight e5 i'm
pretty sure this is sort of the trick
bishop g2 knight d7 and this is why we
played rookie one so that the rook on
fun isn't hanging
and we win some material here even
though there will be probably some
compensation but we win some materials
so he's gone rook g8 uh 2397 and 95
looks kind of interesting but
unfortunately it's not made so we can
take on g2 and queen h7 is just one
check i don't think it works at all i
think he just loses a piece exactly uh
meaning that black basically completely
stabilized he's gone h4 and we can play
knight of fate we can make other moves
as well but let's say we play knight f8
here i was h4th right in knight g5
kind of kind of yeah kind of but
my my larger position takes g5 at the
end
the king can't go to e7 all right but
the larger point is like structurally
you start picking black pretty soon
right you oh gosh yes
c5 rook c8 queen g6 will become a topic
there absolutely
so one day the bishop may slip out to a6
you really need to you really need to
show what you have structurally uh levon
says you know what the knight on f8 is a
great defensive piece but the knight on
f6 will be defensive and offensive let's
trade queens yeah and you kind of have
to accept the trade because if you leave
the the diagonal to to black where do
you go you definitely aren't very happy
and he has accepted the queen trade but
seems very very safe for black i don't
know like in terms of playing for
advantage here with black already i
don't know if i prefer knight f8 or
queen f5 both are very playable
but i i don't see how white is ever
better in this position
the only thing i can imagine peter is
something
crazy he played a4 a5 and maybe now you
play bishop a4 a5 on the board you see
yeah and i was thinking okay he's going
to go bishop he's 83
that's an indication that well he's not
very happy yeah the inclusion of a4a5
does make our situation uh quite a bit
better in terms of because if potential
c5 counter play because it can it can no
longer be safely ignored with the pawn
on a7 black can quite easily just ignore
c5 drop the bishop back and cba b is
never a threat
you want to play c5 he's challenging him
go for it go for it yeah yeah see we
take take we play bishop eight i guess
right yes and this knight is going to
settle in on the e4 square and i start
getting worried
very very quickly these are quite sharp
end games but they they seem to my eyes
to be completely fine for black at the
very least
once again fabi scoring seven and a half
out of eight
lavon very very close six and a half out
of eight and as you said we would be
talking about lavon's outstanding uh
success thus far except for fabi's trump
tip pipped him so to speak uh knight f6
what do you think uh fabi's got to do i
think he's done it
he's done it whether he plays c5 here i
don't think you can ignore it i think
you have to snap snap on c5 and go back
to to f8 i guess he goes bishop d4 here
kind of connecting everything but 97 is
not unplayable at all right
between that you can go
i mean knight default probably equalizes
right now but
that's it yeah is it is it time to just
like really pull the plug and try to you
know simplify into some completely equal
position it might be though
i would look for a parachute uh
emergency escape here
yeah
we do have bishop f yeah
it's a very large move yeah so that
knight d4 does uh
94 maybe you can even pretend for a
little bit but it does look like it
should end in a draw right
bishop before 97 i just don't see the
follow up the pawn on c5 appears to be
and also 94 i was i was less less
enamored with the move 94 because me too
yeah i thought 95 was pretty strong here
with the c6 idea exactly maybe we can no
we can't take you knight e5 bishop d5
okay levon has a very i mean he
obviously hasn't blundered but 95. it's
the only move in the position that you
calculate so this is what you this is
what he said hold on and he just wants
to go knight takes c5 next move knight
b3 will be a threat after so can i can i
toss in c
5 c6
maybe you should try to provoke you to
play f6 peter and then and just
make some pretty attention seems like
i've got this great great he has played
c6 but i don't know if you're pretending
for you know like i'm i'm not buying
black is in any kind of trouble there
but okay
yeah we can also go
we can go b if we don't want to play f6
but we do want to pick up the pawn on c6
eventually we can start with bishop d6
here i guess right
how does that
help you pick up the pawn
i can take on c5 and c6 if i want right
ah and just that way
mechanically yeah yeah but i know i
meant you i i was thinking you're trying
to win the pawn as opposed to just trade
yeah
so i guess he agrees with you about
how annoying the knight on g6 is yeah
could be could be and by the way f7 f6
is one of those positional moves that
you just look at you go
you know you don't really have a talent
for chest
[Laughter]
have you have you considered
backgammon back of an excellent choice
bishop d6
g4 played by um by fabian the meantime
undermining hello hello i kind of like
that move
by the way i i mean power to fabby he's
made a mess out of the position and i
thought
he was on the left maybe
rook e8 i'm provoking f4 or
can i take on f up
excuse me an h2 check yeah
oh dear yeah in the meantime our second
potential game of the day is a kind of a
very very convoluted anti-berlin which
the position is sort of the entire
structure is closed probably ends in a
draw but we don't we're not switching
that was the uh richard yeah richard
wesley herself against wesleyan yeah
yeah he does play rookie uh he has he
took took and played rookie eight
do you take take oh he took on e5 yeah
and and then played rookie eight very
sensitive fabi will be very happy with
these developments i guess even though
i suppose the ig is actually quite
ambitious he wants bishop c7f takes g
what because he has supported the knight
on e4 and he wants f takes g and then
pick up the pawn on c6 this is i thought
this was a lead great it's good it's
good um so do we play a four because of
it
you can still force me with a talented
less move right
but then i go
but then i go gf right
no no i think i think a four is right
actually i think a four of six gf is the
way to go sorry he's gotta get rid of
the giggles
we are you know very on
on
caffeine and nine rounds of blood
exactly i wanted to say we are trading
we are we are trading very very
copyrighted ground and you know ben
might ben might be happy with that
exactly it's his material so we should
be we should be careful here f4 now f6
f6 gf yeah but i think you actually have
to go for it because i really don't like
uh
letting the other options yeah letting
this guy live and something like bishop
c6 might just be an accident yeah from
gf yeah so how seriously do we consider
just going g6 is it like that
no i would consider it i mean that
knight on e4 is kind of like the the
polar key yeah it's so it's a difficult
move to
like i think the the challenge there is
to even think it's possible right let's
take it on g4 yeah all right fg yeah
this will simplify i guess fg is a
decent choice the point obviously being
that if you hang on rookie four where
are you rookie four rookie four f6 now i
guess right
what rook takes has to be here it has to
be there's no other move rook takes e4
here forces the immediate f6
positions it's a yeah d1 too right
right one bishop c6
then rook takes e4
f6 what's the difference
i was going to play rook
c4 but he's still playing bishop yeah
he's gone you know he's gone for the
simpler version of just bishop bishop
and rook takes and f6 uh rook g1
black has this pawn on g4 which still
still has survived but white wants to
land the the d1 rook on d7 and the
opponent c7 is a perennial target here
do we throw in rook a6 i think you throw
in our k6 he's gone if he uh he doesn't
he doesn't want to do it immediately but
you can still do it here maybe he was
rick e6 or rookie sexy you can choose
one of the one of the two yeah because i
think i like rook a6 yeah we need to we
need to support great sex better i just
it feels like that rook on e7 is more
mm-hmm it's more off more
useful
yeah
yeah
i couldn't have said it better myself
i think we've lost it uh folks these
these early wake ups lost it
oh g6 g6 i really am losing it i didn't
see g6 at all
yeah white is completely fine yeah but
should be it should be some kind of a
draw i assume because c3 is too weak
like you go king g7 or king f7 something
like this you prepare rook takes c3
exactly and if c3c4 you will find some
counter play here like a5 is hanging i
suspect even rook a8 is fine but yeah
levon will levon is never putting his
rook on such a square no i get the
feeling that like no
a lot of things have to happen before
levon goes rook create a8 in that
position
yeah literally he is kind of
constitutionally incapable of putting
his pieces on such squares i agree
institutionally
i mean it's the the the the dna just
does nothing
yeah
yeah it just doesn't allow you to make
these types of mistakes
i'm not even sure it's a mistake it's
just like he is not a player that puts
pieces on passive squares i'm not sure
it was that bad to be honest like i
couldn't see any reputation
oh he went wrong a8 uh something i was
expecting maybe a little c6 action there
a moment uh
he's actually in some trouble here
because uh the white rooks are also
becoming quite active uh many of the uh
many of the
two rook positions will be okay here's
also on six yeah both of them don't have
any time at all we should just watch
them play i think it's five against six
seconds
uh white is a bit better but it's
difficult to make any progress here yeah
this is just anything to be saying oh
wow this is just a draw yeah they just i
think so yeah you start pushing the jeep
on because like those those don't
actually run at all fast yeah h5 g5 yeah
and he's got do they i don't think they
do yeah the king the king still gets
there in time rook d6
yeah we can go king of five because c6
we can take and then yeah one c one
correct yeah you you you go over two
yeah you get the king closer and you
make a draw yeah king e4 king e4 now
yeah
well that's a surprise wow
what was that probably still whoa oh
no now it's a drum now
we can jump quickly 84 very ambitious
but still still holds let's jump to the
vichy game for a moment it's a queen and
upon ending four versus three radicals
forever
yeah but he's going to have probably not
going to win though yeah and bishop has
20 seconds against seven which is kind
of useful yeah
um
and the the game i i said was completely
closed down the game between uh richard
and wesley wesley is winning very
comfortably he won in fact yeah that's
actually a very very important result
because he's had a very lackluster day
and we heard wasn't tied for second so
exactly it's a
important result there
i'm surprised that we haven't seen
something like a g4
by white
house young sister doing is better but
maybe not winning maybe maybe
here comes the g4
no it's not going to be winning of
course but at least it's a way of
opening up
uh black's king a little bit well
vicious i think is way too experienced
here to to go badly wrong
he's not even giving checks as you can
see he's just keeping the queen active
and here comes page five trying to break
so we're going to go queen check and we
hope
that
somehow we're
you kind of have to yeah i don't like
queen check actually because it makes it
more difficult for us to take with the
pawn if we take with the queen we never
win it's too uh the pawns are they need
to be split up they need to you know
generate some threats so we take with
the pawn but if you take it it's not
going to be a perpetual pretty much with
the queen on g5 you'll never yeah clock
times peter yeah seven seconds against
half an hour half a minute
[Laughter]
yeah yeah now every king upon end game
will likely be a draw but not everything
they're not yeah
you could do it
that one in particular is a draw yeah
okay
but this one is easier i think
relic is done with this easy yeah
wow wow what a round and let's take a
look at what happened because
oh sorry we still have one more round
let's do this trying against chefchenko
two against one he shouldn't convert
this but it's not
true
it's not yeah these positions are yeah
the the
king on the g6 and uh but it is actually
yeah
yeah you know that's just a rook check
you always attacked you too yeah king h4
even i think was okay
king h4 was okay yeah yeah g5 g4 he
might actually have played himself into
a lost position by by now yeah rook g5
g4 yeah he's just two paws now
you mean even the oh yeah
you don't do anything it is too fast
and this is not the queen ending of two
pawns versus yeah the sun game actually
gets played out because there's some
weird stale matrix but at the end right
yeah at the very very end there are some
weird tricks but
this is why this is why this is why you
see it played out but right it's you
know there's a dozen different ways of
winning it by the time
yeah and if he wins he will be in seoul
second place
outstanding i am right
yeah he's fighting very badly right
yeah
he began by by losing the first uh two
and then drawing in round three and then
he went on a bit of a rampage towards
the end yeah he won the whoa won the
last three
hat trick there to finish the day before
we just go with this one we just
yeah this is the one that miro likes the
most yeah you go g6 check and if king h8
now now h7 just wins but if you go king
h8 you play rook f8 g7 and kg6 this is
the one that mira likes
with understanding with great
understanding and this is also just made
all right good wow congratulations for
dude
nobody was talking about him but he
did have a decent rapid he didn't have a
rapid as good as vicky clearly he didn't
have his rapid as good as richard right
but he did finish
fourth or third in the rapid help me out
there
uh
he was in third place in third place
starting the day finishes the day clear
sacrifice i'll take it i think he'll
take it
with happiness
wow yeah in the meantime uh antoine
corbett of blunder the full rook to the
david david gabriel
rains at
right right and
having not really having an enjoyable
tournament
yeah this was a bit of an unfortunate
moment here between korabov and
gabrielesku you can see the position
three pawns for white two pawns for
black rock and bishop broken bishop rook
takes c3 was uh played in this position
and unfortunately he must have thought
that rook c7 check here trades the rooks
and then you push the pawn
unfortunately rook c7 is not a very good
move
yeah because bishops bishops do go
backwards and well that's pretty much it
oh dear in the richard game let's take a
look at the decisive mistake because it
was closed for a very long time i don't
want to get through the entire blitz
game
but around this point we had a weird
position
just you are still okay as white you can
go knight d b two hold on to this knight
on c4 but you can see this knight on f4
is powerful his bishop is threatening to
trade itself yes maybe black has
technically the worst structure but
because this queen is so much better
than this one then it's obvious who's
playing for the advantage right so
knight db2 held the position together
but unfortunately knight d6 doesn't and
when you
put this knight on f5 which looks great
right it actually doesn't do anything
the knight can't really retreat anywhere
the night is stuck this night is stuck
they're both stuck and black has a
surprisingly easy but effective plan
which is to move the bishop and just run
this pawn forward use it as a battering
ram and then start attacking the c2 pawn
and even though
it seems like a simple plan completely
impossible to stop and this is what
happened in the game richard with the
white pieces started fluttering around
because there's nothing to do and he
eventually gave up c3 to try to get the
queen some space if he didn't do this
then simply queen b1 is going to hit the
knight hit the pawn pick everybody up
remember the knight on f4 is going to
pick up d3 soon so he went for some
desperado ideas but this is nowhere near
perpetual the king runs easily and
wesley took a very important
game here but there is a man that is
eight out of nine incredible results
today for fabiano carona he is in warsaw
with christian kirila
thank you alejandro with the man of the
hour right now number three in the live
rating list in the blitz section fabiano
caruana let's start with the obvious
tell us a little bit about this shirt uh
with these two kitties and the chess
team what's the story behind it
well there's not much of a story uh it's
it's actually the same cap
it is the same guys is this your cat
yeah
excellent well definitely a lucky charm
for you in this one how did you approach
today's uh rounds you started off four
or five points behind the leader what
was your strategy yeah i mean i didn't
think i have much chance in the fight
for anything
and in the first game i blundered a
central pawn against richie
but somehow i won that game i was lucky
that my blunder wasn't very serious and
after that i think i played
quite well
i mean i played a number of quite
excellent games i think for blitz
standards against wesley i was quite
proud of that one and some other games
as well i thought i handled it quite
well
uh so yeah any shaky moments throughout
the day did you feel that at all under
pressure in any of the games well when
you get down to seconds you always feel
under pressure like this game against
bishop was a bit crazy
he ran out of time but i don't know
exactly which moment he did so i think
we played played quite a while after he
ran out of time
uh but i think i was mostly pressing
that game and
definitely winning at various moments
maybe not in the final position but uh
that was a shaky one
and um i don't know i mean there was
you know time scrambles are always quite
nerve-wracking
now almost reminiscent of your run at
the sinkhole cup in 2014. seven and a
half out of eight and eight out of nine
did you find any similarities
no
not at all
um
i mean i normally don't go on runs like
this in blitz but yeah it's also
it is just blitz um
i can't really compare it to
achievements in classical chess which
are at least i value uh significantly
more
uh but anyway it feels very good
especially when you're playing good
chess and i think for the most part i
did five points behind the leader going
into today's rounds two points behind
the leader going into the final day how
do you assess your chances going into
that one if i play like today then i i
definitely have chances um
but yeah every day is different you know
sometimes you think you're in form
sometimes you think you're in bad form
like in rapid i was playing terribly and
then suddenly i played quite well today
and then tomorrow is uh is a whole
nother another story uh it's not
guaranteed that i'll i'll continue
playing like this fabiano
congratulations looking forward to see
your matches tomorrow thank you guys
back to you our congratulations to fabi
most certainly and we wholeheartedly
agree that you played a wonderful
wonderful game against wesley so uh
playing over that game was just
fantastic and here's where we stand and
yeah these are later wow
yeah uh
the same split six six players in the
running for the top prizes and uh
among them which is still safely on top
with 19 out of 27 effective uh young
christopher now in uh clear second and
17 and a half then we have the the two
heroes of of the day
with eight out of nine and seven out of
nine respectively fabian devon rickard
is in uh clear fifth wesleyan isn't
clear sixth
still way too early to write wesley off
he he might go nine minutes
tomorrow absolutely everything can
happen as they players will switch
colors as you say and just play it all
again tomorrow but we have breaking news
uh peter
there there you have it yeah there will
be full coverage of the french adventure
candidates
on this channel i assume yes starting
from you know obviously you know
dedicated to my birthday on june the
17th yes
we don't know the lineup of uh you know
who will be doing what this this still
remains to be seen but
at least you do know that the coverage
will be provided which i'm sure is
joyous news
absolutely
and take a look at our predictions here
after uh four
four days of hard fighting chess
everybody's happy i'm just very
disappointed with vorusian verrusa and
just uh alleging the chamber
marijuana and aronian choices very
impressive when you know you know
and let's jump to warsaw for some final
thoughts
well uh it was a day of surging stories
uh you say fabiano caruana eight out of
nine levon aronian starting with four
out of four that was just an insane
start to today's rounds but it is still
the tiger of madras that is roaring in
this event actually he extended the lead
going into the final day two points
ahead of his nearest competitors well
tomorrow is going to be a fun day of
exciting chess anastasia how about
yourself yeah i'm also very happy with
uh young sister who managed to come back
after not so great start of the day but
then he managed to win some games even
risking sometimes too much but still
showed a really nice play
i'm a bit disappointed with ukrainian
players who couldn't show their best you
know in this tournament because normally
we know that anton and kirill they are
very good blitz players but what to do
it's going to be another day tomorrow
and we will see them again maybe they
will find the way to come back to the
tournament we'll see and i have to say
it's not actually two points is one and
a half points because duda has been
surging in the last three rounds a uh
triple victory for him in the last three
rounds that's going to be an exciting
day tomorrow guys back to you in the
studio in sabres thank you anastasia
thank you christian castling long i
didn't realize that duda had made three
in a row
very very nice and for you uh
alejandro as
christian was saying day of surges day
of surges for me it's a continuation of
good form in blitz from favi and from
levon because remember that it's not
just today where they showed amazing
chess they dominated the american blitz
that we had here a couple of weeks ago
and you can say that's just one
tournament it was just one afternoon but
they were so dominant they crushed the
event they were always boards one and
two from start to finish and today they
just seem to be in a slightly different
level than every other player taking
better advantages of their opponent's
mistake getting in those key moments and
key things better suited to today's fast
chess and
they catapulted themselves i mean the
fact that they are in their rankings
right now in blitz is amazing can they
do it again tomorrow this is going to be
a super exciting finish vishy with a
head start but one and a half points
over this field and two points over favi
and over lavon anything can still happen
tomorrow i personally want to see bishop
finish it off properly but still
anything to play for tomorrow nine
rounds of blitz to finish off this
tournament guys thank you alejandro
peter it's been a pleasure it really is
yeah it's great
and tomorrow will be
sort of just the same
excellent excellent chess plenty of
excitement very very tight tight race
there at the top with people getting
closer and closer to vichy this is as
close as anyone no that's not true
if somebody was at one richard was one
point behind in the start of the day but
since then the the one and a half point
lead that she has
right now is the closest we've had the
pack to him so yeah should be a
fantastic day tomorrow so tune in same
time same place thank you for sharing
your day with us we'll see you tomorrow
good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited